Online.
Online. Ich will online Musik beschwerden bitte an Chaos. Musik beschwerden bitte an President Edvard aus Bangkok.
Sag's nicht.
Chaosradio im Blue Moon bei Fritz. Erstmal kurze Vorstellungen, wer das da ist diesmal.
Na ich bin da Steini, wie eigentlich fast immer. Ich bin auch immer noch Tim.
Andreas ist auch mal wieder dabei und Andi auch.
Schön, ihr seid ja so eigentlich auch die regelmäßigsten, ne? Die anderen fehlen ja öfter.
Welche anderen meinst du denn?
Na, zum Beispiel Wozzen Frank.
Frank, der hütet deine Kinder. Hallo Frank. Du hütet deine Kinder, das ist schön.
Hacking wie Internet. Ihr könnt euch einmuschen hier, ihr könnt Fragen stellen unter chaos.orb.de. Chaos schreibt man übrigens CHAUS. ORB.de, muss ich jetzt nicht extra noch ansagen. Irgendwann wird es auch mal einfache E-Mail-Adressen geben, wahrscheinlich. Obwohl noch einfacher als chaos.op.de kann man es wahrscheinlich machen.
Sag mal, die VENIM-Regeln hier, die auf dem Zettel stehen, sind sie für uns oder für die Hörer?
Die sind für dich, Andi. Die sind für dich, Andi, du Scheiße.
Für uns alle.
Heute sind sie nämlich ganz viel, weil das ja die erste Sendung im neuen Jahr ist.
Ja, frohes neues Jahr.
Ach hier, die VENIM-Regeln.
Jetzt nicht, jetzt nicht.
Johnny, nicht. Kannst du ruhig vorlesen. Nein.
Nein, das lese ich nicht vor.
Aber es ist nötig. Na gut, wir sind alle ganz lieb.
Genau, Tim, fangen wir an.
Apropos Anfragen. Wir haben sogar tatsächlich schon per Mail vorab eine Voranfrage, die sozusagen während der Sendung beantwortet werden soll, bekommen. Wir haben sie zur Kenntnis genommen und wir werden auch darauf eingehen. Allerdings nicht jetzt. Sondern wir wollen jetzt erst mal darauf eingehen, was wir eigentlich heute erzählen wollen. Hatten wir uns nicht darauf geeinigt, dass wir jetzt immer Musik unterlegen? Hacking the Internet, jetzt wird schon ganz sphärisch. Wir wollen heute auf die Aspekte des Hackens insbesondere im Internet gehen. Das ist eigentlich gar nichts Neues. Schon die ersten wirklich bekannt gewordenen Hacks vor vielen Jahren waren tatsächlich Internet-Hacks. Nur, dass es damals so recht keiner realisiert hat, dass es das Internet schon gab. Ich weiß nicht, das datiert, glaube ich, jetzt schon so 5, 6, 7 Jahre zurück.
Ja, 10.
Oder 10. Ich weiß nicht, wann war der Internet warm zum Beispiel?
Muss ans Mikro. Alles klar.
86.
86. Die Antwort war richtig. In der letzten Zeit, wie ihr ja alle wisst, ist das mit dem Hacking und vor allem mit dem Internet alles noch sehr viel populärer geworden. Es gab gerade in den letzten Wochen und Monaten eine ganze Menge interessanter Fälle, die wir heute auch nochmal aufzählen wollen, in denen bestimmte Websites aufgehackt wurden, in denen bestimmte Verschlüsselungsmethoden aufgehackt wurden, wo konkret ein Rechner eingebrochen wurde, wo Daten gestohlen wurden, wo Websites vor allem modifiziert wurden, was natürlich immer eine besondere populäre Wirkung hat, insbesondere bei den Opfern, die diesmal gewählt wurden. Und außerdem ist das Hacking the Internet deshalb interessant, weil wir uns auch gerade in der Zeit befinden, der Transition hin zum Homebanking über das Internet. Das ist ein unglaublich großes und starkes Thema, das derzeit auf allen Ebenen diskutiert wird. Und es sieht halt so aus, als ob es auch noch weiter zunimmt. Es gibt es ja auch bereits schon. Vier oder fünf Banken haben tatsächlich schon Angebote in der Richtung. Und wir wollen auch mal ein bisschen beleuchten. Allerdings wollen wir jetzt nicht schwerpunktmäßig auf Homebanking gehen, sondern nur beleuchten, was eigentlich die konkreten Probleme an dem Internet sind. Warum denn das mit der Sicherheit da so ein großes Problem ist. Denn Datennetze gibt es ja schon länger. Was hast du mir dazu zeigen? Ah, genau, Andi hat recht. Und zu Anfang, ich übergebe jetzt mal an Andi, wollen wir euch noch mal erklären, was wir eigentlich meinen, wenn wir vom Hacken reden.
Und zwar das Ganze, was ich jetzt hier referiere, die Hackerethik, die stammt aus dem Buch, das heißt Hackers, und ist von 1970 oder so. Und damals war es halt so, da gab es sehr wenige Computer, und die mussten sich sehr viele Leute teilen. In diesem Fall waren Studenten. Und die haben im Laufe ihrer Spielereien, ihrer Faszination eben festgestellt, dass im Grunde genommen, man am weitesten kommt, wenn man alles wissen, was dabei anfällt, miteinander teilt. Wenn man einfach sich gegenseitig erzählt, wo die Löcher sind, und wenn man über Probleme auch offen redet. Und ich mach das jetzt mal ganz dogmatisch. Die erste Regel heißt dann auch, der Zugang zu Computern und allem, was einem zeigen kann, wie diese Welt funktioniert, sollte unbegrenzt und unvoll und vollständig sein. Also da wird auch irgendwie klar, wo das Ganze hier kommt. Alle Informationen müssen frei sein. Misstrauer Autoritäten, fördere Dezentralisierung. Beurteile einen Hacker nach dem, was er tut. Nicht nach üblichen Kriterien wie Aussehen, Alter, Rasse, Geschlecht, gesellschaftliche Stellung. Man kann mit einem Computer Kunst und Schönheit schaffen. Computer können dein Leben zum besseren fällen machen. Der Club hat da noch zwei Regeln dran gehängt, die sich im Laufe der Zeit herauskristallisiert haben, die man noch so hinzufügen sollte. Die erste ist Müll nicht in den Daten anderer Leute. Und die zweite ist eine Regel, die wir abgeleitet haben, aus den verschiedenen Hacks in sowohl öffentlichen als auch privaten Bereichen, wo wir dann gesagt haben, öffentliche Daten nutzen, private Daten schützen. Also auf der einen Seite alle Informationen müssen frei sein, damit wir alle irgendwie diesen Planeten so begreifen, die Probleme so begreifen und dagegen auch was tun können. Also nicht nur Computerprobleme, sondern da ist eine Menge Informationen mittlerweile drin gespeichert über alles Mögliche. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich noch so etwas wie eine Privatsphäre und es sollte auch so etwas wie eine elektronische Privatsphäre geben. Wir sagen, wenn man sich irgendwie eine Verlagerung des Lebens ins Netz vorstellt, dann muss man da auch irgendwie mal die Tür zumachen können und seine Ruhe haben können.
Wenn da um welche Fragen zu sind, könnt ihr natürlich auch nach wie vor anrufen. Immer wenn hier so richtig vier Mikros aufeinander sind, klingen wir ein bisschen wie aus einem Null. Das wäre ein Problem, ob das an den Mikros liegt. Könnte an den Mikros liegen, liegt aber einfach daran, dass wenn vier Mikros dicht beieinander sind und alles über alle Mikros rüberkommt, wird der Raum größer. Klingt ein bisschen blöd, aber dann müsst ihr euch dran gewöhnen. Wenn ich euch ausmache, klingt es gleich besser.
Es würde auch besser klingen, wenn wir dich ausmachen würden.
Ach, das eine Mikro, das hier auf der anderen Seite. Das macht nicht viel aus, Tim. Wir haben ein bisschen die Hackergrundregeln gehört. Für viele Leute, die eine Sicherheitslücke in einem System finden, ist das natürlich erst mal ein Sport, oder?
Zum einen ist es ein Sport, zum anderen kann das natürlich auch einen Grund haben. Der ist mitunter auch gar nicht so nett. Und da kommen wir ein bisschen darauf, warum wir diese Sendung jetzt konkret mit diesem Thema machen. Weil letzten Endes geht es ja um die privaten Daten, die geschützt werden sollten. Und das ist im Internet einfach schlichtweg unmöglich. Und zwar auf der Basis, auf der es... Wenn ich den Satz fertig mache, dann stimmt es auch wieder. Auf der Basis dessen, was heutzutage als kommerzielle Dienstleistung angeboten wird, wo einem also vorgegaukelt wird, es sei sicher, in Wirklichkeit ist es das nicht. Und wir wollen heute beschreiben, was da eigentlich unsicher ist. Wir wollen sensibilisieren dafür, wo man aufpassen muss mit seinen Daten.
Aber Steini, das finde ich langweilig. Das klingt so, als würden wir die Systeme irgendwie sicher machen wollen. Also ich finde es völlig in Ordnung, wenn Leute bei amerikanischen oder bei welchem Geheimdienst auch immer hacken gehen und da einfach Daten aus den Rechnern holen, die eigentlich geheim sind und die veröffentlichen. Ich finde das mindestens genauso wichtig, wie irgendwie von mir aus sichere Systeme für das Privatleben. Das Privatleben fühle ich echt lieber ohne Computer.
Ist denn das Interessante nicht daran, diese Verschiebung von Machtpositionen, dass ich praktisch als 15-jähriger Hacker in Zehlendorf plötzlich die Möglichkeit habe, mich mit...
Das ist das sogenannte Mitnix-Syndrom oder man könnte es auch anders betreiben, neben diese Allmacht-Omnipotenz-Fantasien, die Jugendliche natürlich auch ein Stück weit daran treiben, gerade in einer Phase ihres Lebens, wo sie mitunter hier und da anecken oder irgendwie Bewusstseinserweiterungen ausgesetzt sind, dass sie da irgendwie eine Sache haben, die sie regeln können. Wo sie das Gefühl haben, sie können sich irgendwie einsetzen, da kommt sogar was bei raus und da dann eben entsprechend auch die Energie investieren. Aber letztendlich geht diese Streben in die Richtung zu begreifen, was das eigentlich alles ist, zu lernen.
Vor dem Fritz-Kurs-Info vielleicht noch ein paar Sätze zum Thema Hacking und den Anleitungen, den wir euch hier geben, den wir euch aussetzen werden. Es ist vielleicht ganz die Hacker-Ethik, die Andi ein bisschen zitiert hat, ist darüber sollte man nicht grinsen. So was gibt es zum Beispiel, es gibt ja auch ein Etikett, also wie man sich vielleicht im Netz ein bisschen bewegt. Ich glaube, ich schicke pro Tag ungefähr zwölfmal eine Adresse raus, wo man darüber was lesen kann, aufgrund der E-Mails die ich kriege von euch. Dazu gehört zum Beispiel, dass man nicht auf jeden Expeditionen-Namen klickt, wo man eine Mail hinschicken kann und irgendwelche Sülze hinschickt, damit man mal testet, ob der neue AOL-Account funktioniert. Und so geht das eben auch beim Hacking. Da gibt es eine gewisse Ethik, da gibt es Regeln, da gibt es ein paar Sachen, an die man sich halten soll. Wenn also hier über Sicherheitslücken geredet wird, dann setzt euch nicht einfach zu Hause hin und fangt an, irgendwelche Sachen auszuprobieren, nur weil ihr mal gucken wollt, ob das funktioniert.
Richtig, gut gesprochen.
Also ich denke auch, das, was wir hier erzählen, das ist dazu geeignet, um festzustellen, ob das eigene System sicher ist und um die Gefahren zu wissen. Darum geht das. Man muss wissen, womit man zu tun hat. Und das wollen wir aufklären. Und das kann man nicht, wenn man drum rumredet. Deswegen sagen wir, wo sind wirklich die Schwachstellen, wo sind die Punkte, wo das Netz angreifbar ist. Um da auch zu sehen, und das sehe ich anders als Andi, um da auch zu sehen, dass das tatsächlich, was den privaten Bereich angeht, sicherer wird.
Ich denke, da kommen auch nach dem Info noch ein paar Fragen von euch. Wir werden natürlich auch die Telefonleitungen aufmachen dann. 0331 für Potsdam 74 181 110. Die E-Mail-Adresse hier ist chaos.org.de. Und IRC gibt es nicht, oder?
Doch, IRC läuft. Wir haben ja normalerweise die IRC-Gruppe Channel Chaosradio, aber da ist uns irgendein Amerikaner diesmal zuvor gekommen. Der offizielle Chaosradio-Support läuft also diesmal auf dem Channel Chaos-Radio. Chaos-Radio. Und dort sitzt der Felix und wird euch alles im Detail erklären, was wir hier in dem Sinne nicht in der Breite ausgelzen können.
Ihr könnt aber natürlich die Fragen auch alle in Deutsch an diesen Ami stellen, der den Chaos-Radio-Kanal aufgemacht hat. Mal gucken, was passiert.
Februar 1997 gibt es die Webcrash Party. Pils bläht ein. Im Internet, im Radio und auf der Seabase. Die Webcrash Party. Am 4. Februar mit den Webartisten Boish Kasani, mit Johnny Kuttner und Sabine Warmer und mit Hörern aus aller Welt. Live im Netz, live im Radio und direkt von Netz auf der Seabase. Lock dich ein. Am 4. Februar von 20 bis 1 Uhr. Verlinkt, digitalisiert und angeklickt von Fritz.
Das würde uns eine ziemlich große Aktion, und wir werden heute im Laufe dieses Chaosradios, das ihr gerade hier hört, auf Fritz, euch die Möglichkeit geben, live in der Seabase dabei zu sein. Da gibt es eine ganz begrenzte Fläche für Fritz-Hörer und Hörerinnen, wenn ihr dabei sein wollt und hier anruft. Ruft bitte nicht nur deswegen an, sondern wenn ihr was zum Thema zu sagen habt. Dann könnt ihr dahingehen, wir haben eine Guestliste hier. Jeder, der sich dafür interessiert, der ein bisschen in der Materie drin ist, kann dahin. Es müssen aber nicht nur Computerfreaks sein, wie gesagt, weil das auch für alle anderen, glaube ich, ein spannender Abend wird. Der kommende Dienstag, 4. Februar 1997, die Webcraft-Party. Ihr hört Chaosradio, das Thema ist Hacking the Internet. Ach wisst ihr, Scheiß aus Labern, wir hören einfach nur ein bisschen Netzmusik in den nächsten drei Stunden. Erster Anrufer ist da und heißt Tino, hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Jawoll, das ist richtig.
Hi.
Du hast eine Frage zum Hacking?
Ja, das ist richtig. Ihr habt ja nun ein bisschen erklärt, so die ganzen Gefahren des Internets, aber was mir noch so ein bisschen Rätsel ist, wie kommt man denn nun letztlich da rein? Was sind das für Adressen? Welche Pages sind das? Welche Seiten sind das? Wie kommt man rein, um direkt auf die Systemstellung oder direkt in die eigentlichen Seiten zu kommen, um dort irgendwelche Daten zu verändern? Das ist mir nach wie vor ein Rätsel.
Also mit Webpages hat es nicht im eigentlichen Sinne was zu tun. Das ist halt das World Wide Web, aber das World Wide Web ist dabei nur ein Ding auf dem gesamten Internet. Das Internet selber zeichnet sich dadurch aus, dass es sich dabei eben um ein echtes Computernetzwerk handelt. Das heißt, hier sind nicht etwa Menschen miteinander vernetzt, sondern halt Computer. Und das bedeutet, dass jeder Computer faktisch mit jedem anderen Computer zunächst einmal verbunden ist auf einer technischen Basis. Sogegannte Netzprotokolle. Und dort kann man eben noch sehr viel mehr machen, als sich nur Bilder anzuschauen, sondern sind halt permanent auch Programme aktiv und tauschen Daten miteinander aus. Und permanent fällt auch immer wieder dieses Problem der Autorisierung an. Also bist du der, der du meinst, der du bist? Und darfst du das hier eigentlich, und wenn du jemand bist, der das darf, nicht verbrechen?
Ich glaube die Frage setzt noch viel früher an. Oder Tino? Ich denke schon, ja. Also versuch dir mal zum Beispiel ein Netz aus nur zwei Computern vorzustellen. Also nimm mal an. Hast du einen Rechner?
Ja, wäre das eine Art zu vergleichen wie Hyperterminal-Programme oder wie?
Nein, es gibt ja irgendwie eine Ebene, die die meisten Computer, die da miteinander vernetzen, sind Unix-Computer.
Darf ich mal ganz kurz unterbrechen? Ich bin natürlich im Internet, und habe da natürlich die Möglichkeit, von hier nach da zu gehen und mir sämtliche Sachen aufzurufen. Aber was ist das? Ich denke, es muss doch über dieses WBW zu machen sein, wo die Hacker drin sind.
Da ist der Schutz einfach zu einfach.
Das WBW ist ja nur das Angucken von Seiten, die aus Computern abgerufen werden, die mit einem Betriebssystem laufen. Und es gibt zum Beispiel Telnet, das kannst du auch teilweise aus dem Netzgap ausrufen. Das ist dann eine Möglichkeit direkt mit dem Computer zu reden und nicht einfach nur Dateien abzurufen, die dir dann grafisch angezeigt werden. Das ist sozusagen, man geht in den Kommandomodus mit dem Computer und da muss man sich natürlich erstmal einloggen, da fragt er nach einer Autorisierung und da fängt der Spaß eigentlich an.
Jetzt kauft sich jeder Hacker Telnet.
Nein, da gibt es nichts zu kaufen oder so. Wenn du im Internet vor 5 Jahren gearbeitet hast, gab es keine Bilder. Sondern du hast eigentlich nur auf einer Shell gearbeitet. Und Telnet ist eigentlich nur dieser eine Dienst des Internets. Das heißt, du kannst dich ransetzen und hast in einem Textfenster eine Kommandozeile und die benutzt du auf einem anderen Rechner, obwohl du an deinem Rechner sitzt, weil die Rechner sind ja alle miteinander verbunden. Das heißt, du tippst und bist aber eingeloggt in einem Rechner von mir aus Kalifornien.
Und dann kann der in Kalifornien nicht beeinflussen?
Das kann er natürlich bis zu einem bestimmten Grad beeinflussen. Deswegen hab ich vorhin gefragt, ob du einen Computer hast und wollte das auf diese zwei Rechnerebene bringen. Nur zwei Rechner miteinander verbinden, das sind ja ein Netzwerk. Und jetzt sagst du zum Beispiel, dieser andere Rechner, der kann bei mir den Ordner Arbeit und Dateien angucken, aber den Ordner privat, wo deine Briefe drin sind, den soll er sich nicht angucken können. Also so ist das jetzt mal ganz simpel erklärt. Insofern kann es Zugangsberechtigungen vergeben, Zugriffsberechtigung. Und so funktioniert das in großen, natürlich sehr viel komplizierter, auch im Internet.
Gut, was ist denn jetzt nun direkt The Net? Was ist das für The Net?
The Net ist eines der Dienste, genauso wie WWW, ein anderer Dienst ist. Und The Net ist eben der Dienst, wo man normalerweise als Mensch mit einem Computer redet und da eben auf Shell-Ebene den Kommandos geben kann, da Programme starten kann, da er sich weiter verbinden kann oder irgendwie so.
Wie man unter DOS arbeitet.
Und das Hacking über WWW völlig ausschlechthin.
Nee, WWW ist ja per Definition das Abrufen von Seiten.
Naja, also wir werden auch darauf heute noch kommen. Selbstverständlich lässt sich auch das WWW hacken. Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass eigentlich jeder Dienst in seiner Form zu betrügen ist.
Aber nicht auf der WWW-Ebene.
Nee, das gibt es doch nicht als ActiveX.
Na gut.
Unter anderem kann man auch unter Ausnutzung der Fehler des WWW-Dienstes...
Also Timo, ich will jetzt mal, wenn ich ein bisschen gemein wäre, würde ich sagen, wenn du das bei The Net gerade zum ersten Mal gehört hast, wird es sowieso auch noch sehr lange dauern, bis du hacken kannst. Deswegen brauchst du dir darum noch keine Gedanken machen, wie es im WWW ist. Aber so auf die Art, dass du jetzt, weiß ich nicht, dass du zu www.fritz.de gehst und da jetzt was dran verändern kannst, das wirst du nicht schaffen.
Das hab ich mir gedacht.
Merk, also eins ist ganz klar, hacken beginnt man in dem Moment, wo man so viele Kenntnisse über ein System erlangt hat, dass einem die Fehler geradezu in den Schoß fallen.
Gut, ist es aber jetzt, ich habe es jetzt richtig verstanden, nicht kann, wenn ich über The Net verbunden bin, ich muss also im Grunde die Einwilligung haben, über verschiedene Dateien von dem Gegner oder von dem Gegenüber. Ich muss also mindestens eine Einwilligung haben, über ein System in seinen Computer reinzukommen, um dann vielleicht eventuell in andere Dateien reinzukommen.
Oder dich als jemand anderes ausgeben.
Genau, und im Internet ist das deshalb so dramatisch, weil da von vornherein sowieso alle schon mal grundsätzlich miteinander verbunden sind. Da muss nicht erst noch ein Modem wählen und da muss nicht eins abnehmen, sondern alle sind miteinander verbunden, das heißt der Direktzugang ist schon möglich. Quasi die Startsituation, von der aus man hacken kann, die vor wenigen Jahren noch sehr schwer zu erreichen war, die ist im Internet sozusagen Standard.
Genau, und das was du gerade erwähnt hast, nämlich diese Zugangsberechtigung zu den Daten, die nennt man Account, und die werden geschützt durch deinen Namen und ein Passwort. Wenn du dir den Namen und das richtige Passwort eingibst, hast du Zugriff auf bestimmte Dateien. Und wenn man jetzt einen Weg findet, dieses Passwort und diesen Namen irgendwo zu klauen oder herauszufinden, dann kann man das natürlich auch unberechtigterweise. Das ist dann wie ein Schlüssel nachmachen. Und das ist aber nicht so einfach. Und wie das geht und warum das überhaupt geht, darüber reden wir heute.
Seid ihr Hacker oder nicht? Ist ein Hacker unter euch?
Also wir haben in der Ersatzung des Chaos Computer Clubs das Wort Hacken mal drin gehabt, als zu fördernde Tätigkeit. Und dann haben wir versucht mit dieser Vereinssatzung gemeinnützig zu werden. Und dann hat uns das Finanzamt für Körperschaften das irgendwie mit einem richtig echten, großen, roten Filtschrift angestrichen haben gesagt, aber das ist doch irgendwie nicht im Sinne des öffentlichen Interesses. Seitdem steht da statt Hacken Schöpferung, ähm, wie war das noch? Schöpferischer Umgang mit... Schöpferisch kritischen Umgang mit Technologie. Und das trifft auch ganz gut. Also Hacken hat nicht unbedingt was mit Computern zu tun. Aber dazu ein andermann.
Und Hacking ist auch nicht prinzipiell was Böses, sondern kann eben auch dazu dienen, eben die Lücken zu finden, um sie zu schließen.
Genau, da muss jeder hin. Keine Angst, wir sind die guten.
Tolli, welchen Internet Service Provider benutzt du? Also wie gehst du ans Internet?
Ja, ich gehe über BBTT, aber das wird relativ unbekannt sein.
Ja, kenn ich.
Der ist in Berlin, der kennst du. Das ist gut, da bin ich. Der ist in Berlin und relativ klein. Und ich bin auch erst seit, ich weiß nicht genau, seit einem Monat, zwei Monaten drin. Hab natürlich schon eine ganze Menge gemacht. Für die Zeit, relativ, ne? Und naja, jetzt geht natürlich die ganze Fragerei los. Ist ja klar. Ja, natürlich. Man nutzt die Seiten, die da sind, kauft sich Zeitschriften und schaut natürlich rein, guckt, was man machen kann. Und das ist natürlich ein interessantes Thema.
Tino, dann hör noch ein bisschen weiter zu. Vielleicht haben wir noch ein paar interessante Sachen für dich. Okay, bis dann, ciao, danke dir. Jetzt haben wir einen schönen Einstieg gehabt und ein paar Sachen vielleicht ansatzweise erklärt. Das ist natürlich immer total schwierig, da ganz am Anfang anzufangen. E-Mails sind gekommen. Mit der Anfrage gibt es heute auch IRC. Nicht immer nur lesen, auch zuhören. Ja, gibt's. Es gibt einen IRC-Kanal, aber der heißt heute nicht Chaosradio, sondern Chaos-Radio, weil irgendein Ami-Chaos-Radio aufgemacht hat. Hier ist eine E-Mail, da steht drin, geht ihr heute auch ins IRC, sag mal, Leute? Es hat sich schon ein Chaos-Radio gebildet. Wir selber, die hier sitzen, sind natürlich nicht im IRC, weil wir sind zwar multitaskingfähig, aber nicht so sehr. Ist dies die Adresse vom Chaos-Bloomoon? Antworten nein. Ansonsten mail ich vielleicht noch ein paar Kommentare im Laufe der Sendung. Ja, IRC-Kanal ist auch auf. Wir haben die Frage zu beantworten. Kann nicht wahr sein. Also ist ja super, heute mal wieder Chaos-Bloomoon. Etwoolz, also Ami, wer es mit einem IRC-Kanal sagt?
Vielleicht kann man jetzt auch nochmal zurück zum Thema.
Wenn wir zum E-Mail ein Auffordern, muss ich dir auch kurz was sagen.
Das Thema fängt ja auch ein bisschen damit an, dass die Leute irgendwie auf die Idee gekommen sind, Computer zu benutzen und sie zu vernetzen, weil man dann sie noch besser benutzen kann. Und da fängt ein bisschen das Grundproblem an, wo all das, was wir, glaube ich, erzählen, ansetzen. Nämlich, dass Computer ursprünglich nie dazu gemacht wurden, Daten geheim zu halten. Dazu wurden sie schließlich gemacht. Die wurden zum Verarbeiten gemacht, zum Vermitteln, zum Berechnen, zum Zugänglichmachen, zum Vernetzen und so weiter. Aber eben nicht wirklich um die Geheimtheit. Das sind alles dann so nachgebaute Geschichten. Das kann man vielleicht mit einem Gebäude vergleichen, wo vielleicht der ursprüngliche Gedanke mal war, dass man ein Dach über dem Kopf hat und dann ist irgendeiner noch auf die Idee gekommen, dann könnte man auch Türen einbauen.
Mein erstes Computerbuch erklärte mir einen Computer mit einem System, was Eingabe, Verarbeitung und Ausgabe betreibt. Kurz EFA und merkte an, dass mit EFA ja schon immer alle Probleme begonnen hätten.
Ja, dann telefonieren wir mal weiter. Hi, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da? Hallo, hier ist Toni und der Chaos Computer Club.
Ich hätte mal eine Frage und zwei Antiforben. Wenn ich jetzt da mit Netzgeb ins Netz gehe, inwieweit könnten jetzt andere auf meine Daten auf meinen Rechner zugreifen? Oder irgendwie, wie es Microsoft mal gemacht hat, mit der E-Mail, da mal die Daten durchfosten. Inwieweit ist man selbst geschützt?
Was ein Gerücht, das immer noch kommt.
Das kommt darauf an. Wir werden genau das Problem Netzgabs nachher auch noch erwähnen. Ich mach's mal kurz. Hast du deine E-Mail-Adresse in Netzgeb in der Konfiguration eingetragen? Die lässt sich zum Beispiel da schon mal relativ leicht rausziehen. Wenn du damit ein Problem hast, dann hast du ein Sicherheitsproblem. Andere Dinge können auch noch rausgenommen werden. Das werden wir nachher noch im Detail erklären.
Ich mach jetzt mal direkt einen Zugriff auf die Daten, auf Dateien, Verzeichnungen.
Also es ist eigentlich, so wie es angelegt ist, nicht zwingend möglich. Es gab allerdings schon einige Hacks und Demonstrationen, die das möglich gemacht haben. Das basierte allerdings auf Federn in der Software von Netzgeb. Da man allerdings diese Fehler niemals los wird, also diese dann vielleicht schon, aber dann kommen andere wieder dazu, ist natürlich auch ein Webbrowser in gewisser Hinsicht ein Risiko. Das Risiko ist allerdings im Vergleich zu anderen Sachen noch relativ klein.
Aber wenn wir, also ich könnte jetzt aus der Bizette von heute zitieren, da heißt es kleine Programme, die sich durch die Telefonleitung in den heimischen Computer schleichen. Von dort können sie jetzt sogar das Bankkonto kündigen.
Du gerade angesprochen hast, wird definitiv hier noch rauftauen in der Sendung. Ja, dann machen wir erst mal weiter.
Unter dem Namen Internetwarm, also in der technischen Szene zumindest Internetwarm, bekannte Fall. Es war ein kleines Programm, was sich halt im damaligen, noch recht kleinen im Vergleich zu heute, kleinen Internet ausgebreitet hat, das gezielt eine bestimmte Schwäche von einem sehr verbreiteten Mailprogramm ausgenutzt hat. Ein Mailprogramm in diesem Moment ist nicht ein Programm, mit dem man seine Post liest, sondern ein Programm, was auf Computern im Internet installiert ist, um Mail überhaupt weiter zu leiten. Also die eigentlichen Vermittlungssoftware-Module, die Post durch das Internet weiterführen, da wo es hin soll, die hatten bestimmte Fehler. In diesem Fall handelt es sich um das Programm Sendmail. Und es war relativ einfach möglich, mit einem gezielt daraufhin programmierten Programm diesen Fehler auszulösen. Und das Ergebnis ist, wie bei den allermeisten Herkst, danach hatte man den sogenannten Super-User-Zugriff auf den betroffenen Computer. Super-User oder Administrator, das ist derjenige, der sich grundsätzlich um den Computer kümmert, der also auf alle Daten und auf alle angeschlossenen Geräte Zugriff hat. Ein Programm, was diesen Status erreicht hat, kann dann beliebig Unbild treiben. Der Nebeneffekt bei diesem Internetworm war, dass er außerdem noch einen Fehler enthielt, der zu zwei Sachen geführt hat. Erstens, das Programm ist deutlich vor seiner Fertigstellung bereits in das Internet aus Versehen entwischt, hat sich danach manisch verbreitet. Und der zweite Fehler war, dass es danach in einer Schleife hängen blieb und wie blöde nichts tat, was Prozessoren und Computer zu 100 Prozent auslastet, womit alle betroffenen Maschinen, und das waren nicht wenige vor allem, viele in Universitäten und im Militärbereich, komplett lahmgelegt hat. Die waren also nicht ausgeschaltet, aber nichts ging mehr. Mussten alle ausgeschaltet werden. Und es dauerte wirklich sehr lange, bis das Netz wieder seinen alten Status erreicht hat.
Wann war das und welchem Jahr?
Internetworms zehn Jahre her, 86.
Und das war der erste größere Fall von Internet?
Genau, das war der erste, der auch wirklich in die Medien gekommen ist. Das lustige war, es war ein Sohn von jemanden, der ausgerechnet, glaube ich, in der Datenschutzabteilung, Sicherheitsbeauftragte, und er war halt sozusagen der Täter und hat seinem Vater nicht sehr viel Ehre gemacht, aber war halt schon mal im Fernsehen.
Der Vater war übrigens Robert Timores Senior, der sich das Verfahren ausgedacht hat, nachdem die Passwörter unter Unix verschlüsselt wurden. Und der Sohn ist Robert Timores Junior, und zum Vater kommen wir später auch nochmal.
Weitere Klassiker des Internet-Hackings, die vor allem auch in Deutschland bekannt wurden, war der NASA-Hack. Dort ist in ein oder mehrere Systeme, ich weiß nicht, Andi, da musst du mir jetzt mal ein bisschen aushelfen.
Na ja, der NASA-Hack, also Peter Glaser hat das mal so verglichen. Also damals sind irgendwie ein paar deutsche Jungs erstmals im Internet surfen gegangen und das hat eine internationale Polizeiaktion zur Folge gehabt. Heute wird man gerade dazu gezwungen, im Internet zu surfen. Also irgendwie hat sich da in den Dimensionen was verschoben. Weil wenn man das mal so ein bisschen mit den Dimensionen vergleicht, also damals war es eben unheimlich schwierig, da überhaupt einen Zugang zu haben. Das Internet war sozusagen ein militärisches Netzwerk, mehr oder weniger ursprünglich gewesen. Dann hatten sich da ein paar andere Netze zusammengeschlossen und man konnte also über Datex-P, über Telefonmodems, also relativ umständlich einfach da einen Zugang zu Computern haben. Und im Grunde genommen das, was die Hacker damals gemacht haben, war in ein Computer reinzuhacken, um eben reinzukommen, um vor allem weiterzukommen. Also es ging gar nicht so sehr darum, was ist jetzt auf dem Computer los, oder hat man ein bisschen geguckt, irgendwie gut. NASA war natürlich der Knüller, dass man da irgendwelche Berichte über irgendwelche Raketen und Fälle, also ich entsinne mich, wie wir uns totgelacht haben, wie sie da von ihren Testraketen berichtet haben, die ihnen quer durch die Lagerhalle geschossen sind und fast irgendwelche Putzfrauen noch auf dem Weg mitgenommen haben. Das waren dann irgendwie mal spektakuläre Informationen, aber im Grunde genommen waren das hauptsächlich z.B. CERN. CERN ist so ein Kernforschungsinstitut in der Schweiz. Das hat einfach da einen riesigen Teilchenbeschleuner und eine Menge Computer. Und im Grunde genommen zählen die Teilchen, also irgendwie Atome oder was auch immer, da durch die Gegend schießen. Und die haben eine Menge Computer. Da konnte man irgendwie rumhacken, aber so richtig anfangen mit diesen Nullen und Einsen und diesen Messwerten konnte man eigentlich nicht. Da ging es eigentlich darum, Spaß zu haben. Und Spaß zu haben und diese Computer kennenzulernen. Und teilweise gab es dann diese kleinen David-Goliath-Spiele mit dem Systembetreiber. Also da wurden interne Mails der Systembetreiber abgefangen. Da erinnere ich mich an eine Geschichte, wo dann irgendwie der Elend Silbermann sich tierisch aufregte, meinte, wir haben die deutschen Hacker hier und den und den und den Computer. Und dann hatte also die anderen Systembetreiber angewiesen, noch die und die irgendwie Zugänge zu sperren. Und daraufhin wurde er dann aus seinem eigenen Computer ausgesperrt. Und nicht nur das, von den Hackern. Genau, als er sich denn das nächste Mal versucht hat in seinen eigenen Computer einzulocken, hat er einen sogenannten Audit ausgelöst. Es ist also eine Sicherheit. Man muss sich das vorstellen wie eine Alarmanlage, die eben automatisch meldet, jetzt ist da ein Hacker da. Und dann sitzt der Systembetreiber selbst da, versucht da irgendwie sich ganz normal einzulocken und auf einmal löst er so einen Alarm aus und die Bullen kommen. Also das war ein Riesenspaß. Aber im Grunde genommen war es das auch. Also es war irgendwie ein bisschen spielen und ein bisschen kennenlernen, worum es geht. Aber es war nicht so richtig zweckgebunden, außer eben gut zu lernen.
Wie funktioniert das? NASA und Internetworm, das war das schon ein bisschen her. Was waren jetzt die kuriosen Sachen der letzten Zeit im Internet?
In letzter Zeit gab es irgendwie gut verschiedene Geschichten. Also zum einen ist es halt in Amerika es ist im Moment so ein Sport geworden. Eben alle möglichen Firmen, die sich unbeliebt machen, oder auch Regierungsinstitutionen, wie zum Beispiel das amerikanische Justizministerium, die CIA, die Air Force, eben deren Computer zu hacken, so dass wenn man deren Webseiten aufruft, man eben was ganz anderes bekommt. Das letzte Moment, was man da bekommt, das lässt sich auf so eine ganz grobe Formel bringen, also Pornos, Nazi-Bilder und Hillary Clinton. Das ist so das, was in der amerikanischen Öffentlichkeit einfach die drei ekligsten Sachen, die also in Amerika am meisten Abschaum erzeugen. Also irgendwie Pornobilder. Ja gut, keine Ahnung. Hillary Clinton finde ich, ich meine, die Nazi irgendwie obszön. Das waren ja keine Nackenbilder oder so.
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz erklären, was tatsächlich dort passiert ist. Also die Home Pages, die erste Seite, oder die Hauptseite der Websites von diesen Organisationen, die wurden halt mit einem anderen, durch anderen Inhalt ersetzt. Das geht, das passt auch irgendwie zu der allerersten Frage, die wir gehabt haben, wie ist das mit dem World Wide Web? Also der Effekt war, dass man andere Bilder und Seiten gesehen hat. Diese Modifikation wurde natürlich nicht mit Hilfe von Netzgeb vorgenommen, sondern hier ist aktiv eigentlich, soweit ich informiert bin, auf den Hauptrechner dort, wo die Seiten abgespeichert waren, dort wurde ein Zugang gehackt, das ist immer noch relativ leicht möglich. Es handelt sich dort in der Regel um Unix-Systeme, die haben wirklich schwere Gewunden und man muss halt nur mal gucken, wo man reinstochert, dann findet man in der Regel auch schnell was, sodass man Zugang zu dem System bekommt und dort einfach Dateien austauschen kann. Wenn man erstmal einmal drauf ist, dann ist der Rest eigentlich nur noch Kinderkram.
Da muss man jetzt nochmal ergänzen.
Von daher waren die auch sehr nett, weil sie haben ja nicht irgendwie subtil Informationen eingeschlichen, die jetzt irgendwie noch als wahr hätten wahrgenommen werden können, sondern es war wirklich eine komplette Verballhornung, eine komplette Ersatz, sodass sie das natürlich auch sofort merkten. Aber der Ergebnis war, dass sie wirklich alle Rechner komplett abgeschaltet haben, die am Internet waren, sowohl bei der Airforce als auch bei der CIA.
Da muss man nochmal anmerken, dass das natürlich Rechner waren, die außerhalb eines internen Schutzmechanismus, zum Beispiel der CIA, existieren, um eben auch den Zugang von außen zu ermöglichen. Also die Schnittstelle zu dem Volk.
Man ist nicht wirklich in den Rechner der CIA.
Man ist nicht an die geheimen Daten gekommen, sondern an einen Rechner, der wirklich davon gedacht hat.
Aber teidig ist das schon. Ich meine, bei der CIA sollte man schon davon ausgehen, dass ihre Computer ein bisschen unter Kontrolle haben. Und dann nachher die Behauptung, das ist ja intern, extern und Firewall hier und Firewall da. Auf das Stichwort kommen wir später noch. Also es gibt da so elektronische Brandmauern, die Vorhackern schützen sollen. Nach außen hin ist das total egal. Also am meisten Angst haben die Firmen doch von der Rufschädigung. Und davor, dass einfach offensichtlich wird, dass ihre Computer nicht unter Kontrolle haben. Und das ist auch das Ziel, zumindest dieser amerikanischen Hacker, eben Leute bloßzustellen, die in die Hosen runterzulassen und zu sagen, guck mal, wie doof die sind.
Das Problem ist nur, dass natürlich so eine Veränderung der Seiten, also wenn ich Grafiken ganz groß verändere, sodass der Inhaber dieser Seiten das sofort merkt, dann stelle ich das fest, wenn ich Glück habe, nach 10 Minuten schon, und kann sie wieder herstellen. Und dann ist die Sache wieder erledigt und kann mein Passwortsystem überprüfen oder was weiß ich. Aber wenn ich irgendwo statt einer, wenn da steht 2 Millionen irgendwas und ich mache daraus 20 Millionen, ist das ein Fehler, den man vielleicht erst in ein paar Jahren entdeckt, der aber in der Zwischenzeit eine ganze Menge Schaden anreicht.
Vielleicht haben die Jungs ja auch ein trojanisches Pferd installiert. Wer weiß das schon?
Vor allem, das ist ja nur die Spitze des Icepacks. Das sind die Hacks, die man sieht. Es gibt viel mehr, das man nicht sieht. Also es gibt ja auch noch das Stichwort irgendwie Wirtschaftsspionage und was da unterwegs ist. Das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Also das sind irgendwie die zwei, drei Fälle, die wir hier zitieren können, weil sie so offensichtlich sind.
Es war allerdings auch eine Propaganda-Aktion. Soweit ich weiß, die CIA-Website wurde gehackt von Leuten aus Schweden, die damit sozusagen einen Protest verbunden haben gegen ein Verfahren, was gegen einen schwedischen Hacker läuft. Also das war sozusagen ihre Methode, der Sache Öffentlichkeit zu verschaffen.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass die CIA irgendwie von anderen Amerikanern gehackt wurde, um irgendwelche Sicherheitsbudgets nur zurecht zu fahren.
Verschwörungstheorien hatten wir vor ein paar Monaten.
Wir machen jetzt mal wieder Musik. Wir müssen noch mal ein bisschen laufen. Ich dachte, die Musik ist eigentlich sehr nett.
Die ist aber sowieso in 30 Sekunden vorbei.
Aber die ist schon wieder unter der Strecke.
Ich fahre diese Musik raus.
Ist doch gleich vorbei.
Gefällt sie dir nicht mehr?
Wir reden über Sicherheitslücken im Radio. Wir sind ja hier auch schon gehackt worden. So ist ja nicht damals mit dem VW-Bus. Wir reden über Sicherheitslücken im Internet. Wir reden über Hacking im Internet. Wenn man sich ein bisschen in die Materie einliest, muss man irgendwann feststellen, dass es doch oft eigentlich nur Dummheit ist der Leute oder Unwissenheit der Leute, dass sie eigentlich überhaupt nicht wissen, wo Lücken in ihrem System sind. Ich würde mir zum Beispiel nicht einen Server hinstellen, bei mir zu Hause, wo irgendwelche wirklich wichtigen Sachen drauf sind, weil ich mit dem Wissen, was ich habe, einfach nicht sicher sein könnte, dass ich alle Tricks kenne.
Dein Wissen ist ja zumindest schon so weit, dass du dem bestraust. Manche Leute haben noch nicht mal dieses Wissen, dass es überhaupt notwendig ist, dem zu misstrauen.
Da haben wir gerade neulich so eine Geschichte erlebt, da lief uns einer an und gab uns einen URL durch. URL heißt Universal Resource Locator. Das ist also so eine Adresse, zum Beispiel für Websites. In diesem Fall war es eine Website, die man abrufen konnte. Und da war man, ohne dass da überhaupt eine Kennwortabfrage oder irgendwas war, direkt in der Buchhaltung eines Unternehmens drin. Das war die Firma Pulsar Games in München, die also so eine Art elektronischen Spielsalon im Netz betreibt, wo man eben mit Kreditkartennummern als Grunde dann irgendwelche Wetten machen kann und dann eben Beträge gewinnen kann oder auch nicht. Und man konnte also, indem man in der Buchhaltung war, da brauchte man nur noch sagen, welche Kreditkartenfirma, welcher Abbruchungsdatum. Und dann konnte man eben die Kreditkartenabbrechnungsdaten aller Kunden abrufen, so mit irgendwie Verfallsdatum und Geheimen und Fallera und Kundenname auch. Und ich hab das zuerst für eine Verarschung gehalten. Ich dachte also so blöd kann da keiner sein. Kein Kennwort, gar nichts. Das ist wirklich so schimpansensicher. Die Benutzeroberfläche auch. Also da musste man keinen Computerfreak zu sein. Man musste nur diese Adresse wissen und dann konnte man alles abrufen. Und dann hab ich bei Visa angerufen, da kenn ich so einen Sicherheitsmuffi. Dann hab ich ihm also ein paar von diesen Kreditkarten nochmal durchgegeben und ihn gefragt, ob das irgendwie eine Verarschung ist oder stimmt. Und er meinte, nee, nee, das sieht echt scheiße aus. Also irgendwie, das kann nicht angehen. Und dann hab ich, also das war irgendwie Freitag 17 Uhr oder so, hab da bei dieser Firma grad noch den Geschäftsführer erreicht. Und die meinte so, gut, aber man, sie haben ein Problem. Sie haben praktisch ihre Buchhalte im Internet veröffentlicht. Die ist da einfach so abrufbar. Und dann riecht der da sich also tierisch auf. Man sagt, das kann doch überhaupt nicht angehen. Wer soll denn auf diese Adresse kommen? Das ist doch so gut wie sicher und überhaupt. Also und er wollte echt mit mir diskutieren. Er wollte mich echt überzeugen, dass das jetzt irgendwie sicher war. Und ich hatte aber da überhaupt keine Lust drauf. Ich hatte auch mit dem mit Visa noch mal gesprochen. Wenn so eine Firma ihre Kunddaten veröffentlicht, dann ist die dafür schlicht haftbar. Ich hab denen dann gesagt, wenn sie von ihrem Computer nichts verstehen, dann schalten sie ihn ab. So, schalten sie ihn echt besser ab, weil das ist echt besser für sie. Und das hat er dann auch gemacht. Und ich meine, dann im Hinterhinein haben wir da irgendwie eine kleine Pressemitteilung rausgemacht und so ein Kram, weil das war wirklich sowas von dumm dreist. Das ist mir noch nicht untergekommen. Und jetzt behauptet er, ja, da wäre ja kennen weiter gewesen. Und dies und das. Also jetzt behauptet er irgendwelche harnenbüchenigen Geschichten, aber das war schlicht so, dass man da nur diese geheime in Anführungszeichen Netzwerkadresse wissen musste und...
Man muss sich vor Augen führen bei der Geschichte, dass die Weitergabe dieser URL, also dieser WWW-Adresse in bestimmten Newsgroups wahrscheinlich innerhalb von ein, zwei Stunden dazu geführt hätte, dass da ein Milliardenroher Schaden entstanden würde.
Vor allem wäre die Firma Bankrott gewesen hinterher. Das kann man wirklich eigentlich so...
Fragt man sich natürlich, warum ihr so gute Menschen seid?
Ach, weißt du, das fragen wir uns auch manchmal.
Hat denn die A mit der Hackerethik zu tun, B mit meiner Mutter vermutlich, mit unserem Glauben an das Gute? Nee, ich meine, sonst säßen wir auch nicht hier. Es hat irgendwie schon damals, als er so anfing mit dem CCC und da zu Demonstrationszwecken dieser BTX-Hack irgendwie war, da hat mal jemand so einen Text geschrieben, wenn das rauskommt, wo wir reinkommen, kommen wir da rein, wo wir nicht mehr rauskommen. Und das galt es eigentlich immer ein bisschen zu verhindern, im Sinne von einer legalen und schöpferisch-kritischen, aber in erster Linie mal Bewusstseinserweiterten und informationslos fördernden Tätigkeit.
Warte, kann der sagen, was da anders ist.
Der hat heute auch wieder Lexikon geblättert.
Ach so, lieber mal wieder.
Diese Pulsersache ist, da gibt es noch einen interessanten Hintergrund, denn ich kenne nicht die genauen technischen Details. Und weil ich informiert bin, handelt es sich dabei sozusagen um eine integrierte Bürolösung. Es gibt in zunehmendem Maße sogenannte Workgroup Software, die den gesamten Informationsfluss, der typischerweise in Firmen abläuft, von der Software her schon strukturiert. Also dieses typische Nachricht bringen, Notiz hinterlassen, Termin machen und so. Das kommt mehr und mehr alles in ein Ding. Und nicht selten sind ja diese Informationen, die dabei anfallen, auch die Informationen, die man in das Netz stellen möchte. Sodass es natürlich naheliegt, genau das gleiche System, wenn nicht sogar dasselbe, dafür zu benutzen. Und so was ist dort wahrscheinlich passiert. Sie haben sich dann einfach die Möglichkeit geschaffen, ihre ganzen Buchungen auch mit Netzgelb von ihren Rechnern aus zu machen. Und freuten sich wahrscheinlich schon, wie toll das funktioniert. Haben dabei aber vollkommen übersehen, dass halt die Außenwelt, sprich Internet, irgendwie mehrere Millionen User, das also ganz genau so tun konnte. Und solche Büro-Komplettlösungen gehen jetzt passenhaft.
Da stellt sich dann aber die Frage, wer...
Die kommen teilweise, kommt die Software sogar selbst über das Internet.
Also, wer mag da jetzt schon sein, ne?
Da ist noch viel Spaß drin.
Wir werden versuchen jetzt mit euch am Telefon detailliert zu sein. Also wir wollen ganz bestimmte Details dann über die reden. Das heißt, wenn jemand ganz detaillierte Fragen hat zum Thema Sicherheit im Netz oder so, dann anrufen. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt so wirklich die Grundsachen.
Wir werden erstmal ein paar Sachen erklären, die jetzt vor allem gerade in der letzten Zeit neu hochgekommen sind. Also hot, hot new stuff sozusagen. Es gibt nämlich da, also viele Leute haben viel darüber nachgedacht, wie man das Netz also jetzt richtig aus den Angeln heben kann. Und da das Internet in der Form immer noch im Prinzip ein Studentenhack ist, gibt es noch viele Sicherheitslücken, aber es gibt vor allem auch sehr viele konzeptionelle Schwächen. Das Internet, so wie es also heute läuft, also der technische Aufbau, die Netzwerkprotokolle, die sind zwar wohl ideal für das, was damit gemacht wird, sind allerdings auch ideal, genau das Gegenteil zu tun, oder das, was da läuft, auch genauso gut einfach zu Fall zu bringen. Da kann man so tun, als wäre man ein anderer Rechner. Das ist schon mal ein Problem. Wenn der andere nämlich ihm das einfach glaubt und darauf seine Sicherheit aufbaut, ist schon wieder ein Tor offen. Dann ist es relativ einfach, auch die Dienste, die ein anderer Computer anbietet, sozusagen aus der Ferne einzustellen. Es gibt doch einen schönen Begriff dazu.
Das nennt sich die Night of Service.
Genau, 100 Punkte. Und dann gibt es noch Attacken, mit denen man andere Rechner schlicht und ergreifend zum Abstürzen bringt. Vor ein paar Wochen ist irgendwie rausgekommen eine Methode, wie man wirklich nur mit einem, ich betone mit einem einzigen TCP IP Netzwerk Paket einen Computer, mehrere Computer zum Abstürzen bringen kann. Da steht dann nur noch irgendwie schlimme Fehlermeldungen oder einfach gar nichts und dann ist Ruhe im Karton. Und wenn man nicht hingeht und den Rechner wieder neu einschaltet, dann ist da halt erstmal eine Weile lang nichts.
Gut, detailliertere Fragen von euch könnt ihr hier stellen bei uns natürlich entweder per E-Mail chaosradop.de, orb.de oder per Telefon.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 1 1 0.
Wir hätten dann jetzt gar einen Anrufer, der was zu ekt ist extra.
Hier ist Chaosradio und da ist die Zeit.
Wunderbar.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Da muss man dann schon Hallo sagen, wenn man am Telefon dran ist. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Du klingst ganz schlimm.
Böse Husten.
Ja, hallo.
Ja, wir dich aber kaum. Auf welcher Raumstation bist du?
Hör ich gerade eure Sendung. Das Problem bei mir, ich bin über T-Online mit Netzgeb im Internet.
Das ist doch Internet-Telefon.
Ja, habe ich mir aber jetzt sagen lassen, mich hat es noch nie so richtig gestört, aber dass es sehr, sehr langsam im Aufbau ist.
Ja, das ist aber eine Frage, die wir jetzt wirklich nicht beantworten können. Also das ist jetzt überhaupt nicht unser Thema. Es geht um Sicherheitslücken im Internet und außerdem hören wir dich ganz schwer. Da musst du irgendwie, also es ist kurze Frage, kurze Antwort. Ja, T-Online ist sehr langsam. Muss man nichts zufügen, ne? Woodpeckers from Space.
Ja, ja, viele Anrufe.
Johnny, hi.
Hallo?
Alle leidungvoll, hat er gesagt.
Hat jemand gesagt, dass Computer benutzt ein bisschen? Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio. Ah, na wunderbar. Du kannst reden.
Und zwar geht es uns folgendes. Wie ist es denn erstmal prinzipiell möglich, in so ein Unix-System reinzukommen? Ich meine, ich log mich ein, da wird mein Name abgefragt, Passwort, etc. Und ich wäre abgewiesen, also in der Regel, wenn man keinen Zugang hat und weiß ja nicht mal, ob es diesen Namen gibt, war es nur falsch, weil so prinzipiell fängt man da Datenpakete ab oder wie?
Na ja, es gibt prinzipiell mehrere Möglichkeiten. Zum ersten ist es richtig, dass man als erstes eine Möglichkeit braucht, auf dem Rechner Programme auszuführen. Also muss man sich entweder über The Net einloggen, dazu braucht man natürlich vorher einen Namen und braucht auch vorher das Passwort. Und das kann man zum Beispiel bekommen, indem man sich die Liste der verschlüsselten Passwörter besorgt. Es gibt da zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder man hat jemanden, der die kopiert, der schon auf dem Rechner drauf ist. Oder aber es gibt da das sogenannte YP oder auch NIS, Network Information Services, wo diese Passwortliste über mehrere Rechner verteilt wird. Und unter Umständen kann man die auch von außen abfragen. Kann dann versuchen, Standardpasswörter zu verschlüsseln, sprich Wörterbücher, und versuchen einen Account zu finden, der ein einfaches Passwort hat, nämlich eins, das im Wörterbuch steht.
Genau, es gibt eine weitere Möglichkeit, nämlich die, dass das Netzwerk schlecht gewartet ist und einen Gastzugang bietet, man sich über den Gastzugang einloggt, und dass dann zufällig noch das Passwortfile, also die Datei, wo alle verschlüsselten Passworte, ohne dass ich sie jetzt lesen könnte, drinstehen, und ich mir die einfach ziehen kann. Und dann zu Hause wochenlang rechnen, lasse meinen Computer, um ein paar Passwörter rauszufinden.
Und wie läuft das so allgemein bei diesem Firewall-System? Da ist doch ein extra Rechner, der nur überwacht, was kommt rein, was geht raus.
Wie kommt man da vorbei?
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Das ist doch Technik.
Naja, der einfachste Weg ist, du hackst den Firewall, das heißt du wirst Administrator auf diesen Computer.
Das brauchst du ja nicht. Diese Firewalls werden stark überbewertet. Was eine Firewall ist, ist in dem Sinne auch überhaupt nicht definiert. Es gibt da ganz verschiedene mögliche Stufen von Sicherheitsebenen. Und in der Regel ist es gar nicht mal so viel.
Naja, bloß wenn man es immer so hört, die tun immer so als ob es ein System ist.
Denn Sicherheit ist Vertrauensache.
Also man braucht quasi einen Zugang zu so einem System.
Das ist die eine Möglichkeit. Die andere Möglichkeit ist, andere Services auf dem Rechner zu benutzen. Also außer diesem Telnet Zugang, zu dem man sich hin verbinden kann, gibt es ja noch mehr Services auf dem Rechner. Wie zum Beispiel Airshell oder NFS oder WWW oder Mailaustausch, alles Mögliche. Und jedes einzelne von diesen Programmen stellt eine mögliche Sicherheitslücke dar. Zum Beispiel bei Airshell wird man nicht nach einem Passwort gefragt, sondern der Rechner guckt, ob man von der richtigen Adresse kommt. Und wenn man von der richtigen Adresse kommt, wird man raufgelassen. Und es gibt jetzt Mittel und Wege, so zu tun, als würde man von einem Rechner aus dem lokalen Netzwerk kommen, indem man einfach in die IP-Pakete, die man benutzt für die Verbindung, eine falsche Adresse reinschreibt.
Also du fälligst sozusagen deinen eigenen Absender.
Na ja, haben sie jetzt auch gemacht im USA mit diesem großen Hack, wo sie den Provider, das war doch auch so ähnlich, mit diesen unbekannten Rechnern.
Ich weiß nicht genau, es sind zwar Sachen, die leicht verwechselt werden, das ist einmal das IP Spoofing auf der einen Seite, das ist halt das Fälschen der Absenderadresse und dann die sogenannten Syn Attacken, wo man dem Rechner vorspielt, man würde zu ihm hinconnecten, um eine Verbindung, zum Beispiel eine Webverbindung aufzubauen, aber dieses Protokoll nicht weiterführt. Und dann ist sozusagen eine halb aufgebaute Verbindung in Rechner, in einem Puffer drin, und dieser Puffer läuft irgendwann voll und kann dann keine weiteren Verbindungen annehmen.
Das heißt, man verbindet sich immer und immer wieder auf diesen Computer, ohne dann weiterzumachen und irgendwann kann der nicht noch eine Verbindung akzeptieren. Dann antworte der nicht mehr und dann kann man so tun, als sei man der, der da nicht mehr antworte, zum Beispiel.
Das üben wir denn heute Nacht mal. Weil alles klar kam. Ah, jetzt ist klar. Also ich sitze hier und höre ganz fasziniert zu bei solchen Sachen dann.
Manche Leute rufen an und naja, okay, aber haben echt keine Ahnung.
Das ist ja auch völlig okay. Ich weiß, was du meinst. Also die Frage, wenn zum Beispiel der Begriff The Net noch überhaupt nicht bekannt ist. Wir wollen schon hier auch detailliert und auch technisch wirklich auch für die Leute darauf eingehen, die schon ein bisschen mehr Durchblick haben. Weil das Ding ist, es gibt ja für den Computer Einsteiger, gibt es ja massig Material. Also der Markt ist ja voll mit, mein Computer, so funktioniert's. Ja, die Leute werden natürlich da viel verarscht, aber das ist nun mal so. Ich meine, wenn alle Computersysteme einfacher wären als Windows, dann bräuchte man auch nicht Zeitungen jede Woche rausbringen, wo steht Windows, so benutzlich ist. Also dann würde vielleicht auch eine Anleitung reichen. Aber wir versuchen hier schon ein bisschen in die Tiefe zu gehen. Also für die Leute, die ein bisschen von diesen Einsteigermagazinen alle schon ausgelesen haben.
Dir auch, tschau.
War das richtig gesagt so? Deswegen halt auch so, ob jetzt online langsam oder schnell ist, da wollen wir gar nicht richtig drüber reden. Hallo, Chaosradio hier, wir reden über Hacking im Internet.
Ja, hallo, der Daniel aus dem Speckgürtel. Frage zu den immer wieder auftauchenden PGP-Crack-Urtilities. Gibt's das, auch wenn man da, weiß ich nicht, ein langer Bitschlüssel verwendet, ist euch da irgendwas von bekannt? Oder ist das immer noch eine relative Sicherheit?
Ja, also es gibt da mehrere Geschichten beim Cracken von PGP, und zwar...
Warte mal ganz kurz, PGP-Verschlüsselungssystem für E-Mail. Also womit man seine E-Mail selber schiffrieren kann. Bisher als sehr sicher geltend. Und da gibt es jetzt irgendwelche Programme, die das wieder auch entschlüsseln können sollen.
Ja, und zwar basiert PGP auf der Kombination von zwei Verfahren. Einmal ein asymmetrisches Verfahren, sprich RSA, wo es einen geheimen und einen öffentlichen Schlüssel gibt. Dann einen symmetrischen Verfahren, wo ein Sessionkey verwendet wird, der verwendet, was einfach schneller geht und der dann selber wieder mit dem asymmetrischen Verfahren verschlüsselt ist. Und der Punkt dabei ist, dass man sowohl das asymmetrische wie auch das symmetrische Verfahren angreifen kann. Der Effekt ist in beiden Fällen derselbe. Man kann den Text lesen. Und bei dem asymmetrischen Schlüssel, da wird RSA verwendet. Es ist so, dass der Rekord für das Knacken von Keys ich glaube bei 384 Bits steht. Und man davon ausgeht, dass Institutionen in der Lage sind bis zu 512 Bits zu knacken. Das heißt, wenn man einen Schlüssel von 1024 Bits oder größer verwendet, kann man guten Gewissens davon ausgehen, dass der sicher ist. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es diesen symmetrischen Schlüssel. Da wird IDEA verwendet. Und IDEA hat einen Schlüsselraum von 128 Bits. Und man geht eigentlich derzeit davon aus, dass es noch nicht zu knacken ist. Es gibt aber noch eine weitere, dritte Geschichte. Und zwar der geheime Schlüssel, den man verwendet, um seine Mail zu signieren und zu entschlüsseln, ist auch wieder verschlüsselt aus Sicherheitsgründen. Man muss dann, wenn man PGP benutzt, ein Passwort eingeben. Mit dem Passwort wird der Schlüssel entschlüsselt. Und es gibt jetzt Programme, die, wie wieder bei dem Unix Crack Utility, eine Liste von Wörtern durchprobiert, ob die nicht vielleicht als Passwort gehen oder nicht.
Also das heißt, sie greifen nicht den Algorithmus von PGP an, sondern sie greifen die Unzulänglichkeiten der Unix-Systeme an.
Nein, sie greifen die Unzulänglichkeiten des Passworts an. Also wenn man ein Passwort wählt, dann kann es halt passieren bei vielen Leuten. Das ist ein sehr einfaches...
Aber auch hier kann man davon ausgehen, wenn man das...
1997 gibt es die Webcrash Party. Kurz blät ein. Im Internet, im Radio und auf der Seabase. Die Webcrash Party.
Am 4.
Februar mit den Webartisten Boish Kasami. Mit Johnny Kuttner und Sabine Warmann. Und mit Hörern aus aller Welt. Live im Netz, live im Radio und direkt vernetzt auf der Seabase.
Lock dich ein.
Am 4. Februar von 20 bis 1 Uhr. Verlinkt, digitalisiert und angeklickt von...
Bye!
Ich hab gesagt, es gibt eine URL. Diese URL ist ganz einfach zu merken. www.nonomizer.com Also anonymizer, A-N-O-N Y-M-I-Z-E-A Das ist eine URL, von der aus man andere URLs im Web anwählen kann und da wird die Information, die automatisch mit drübergegeben wird, wird rausgefiltert vorher. Sozusagen so ein Proxy-Proxy oder keine Ahnung, wie man das nennen will.
Ja, es ist nicht der einzige, es gibt da noch sehr viel mehr.
Das ist ja, da vielleicht erst mal zum Merken oder so.
Es garantiert ja aber niemand, dass der Mensch, der den betreibt, nicht diese Informationen besonders gut auswerten kann.
Also von da kommt man von dieser Seite, zum Beispiel gibt es auch eine Menge, da kann man sich noch einiges durchlesen, wie das funktionieren soll. Man kann auch einfach mal unter den bekannten Suchmaschinen wie Yahoo oder Lycos oder so eine Suche nach Security machen, da gibt man massig Informationen zum Thema. Es gibt anonyme E-Mail-Dienste, gibt es inzwischen auch wieder. Nicht ganz so glaubhaft insgesamt wie Anonpet Finland, aber gibt es wieder. Also es gibt, man kann E-Mail-Accounts einrichten im WWW, ohne dass man da seinen wirklichen Namen eingeben muss oder so eine Geschichten.
Aber auch dabei vertraut man natürlich nur wieder anderen.
Der Vorteil bei E-Mail natürlich ist, dass man mehrere hintereinander hängen kann. Und dann, wenn einer von fünf dabei ist, der vertrauenswürdig ist, hat man trotzdem einen sicheren Zugang.
Was machen wir jetzt? Weiter telefonieren oder noch was erklären?
Kurz erwähnen, wer Web-Adressen und andere E-Mail-Adressen, die wir hier so von uns geben, nicht so schnell mitschreiben kann. Der hat auch die Möglichkeit sich bei uns auf der Chaosradio Home Page in eine E-Mail-Verteiler eintragen zu lassen. Der Chaosradio Ticker, der tickert insbesondere nach den Sendungen mit all dem Input, den wir hier von euch bekommen haben und was uns noch so eingefallen ist. Dazu geht ihr auf die www.homepage.ch von Chaos Computer Club, www.ccc.de-chaosradio oder guckt euch die Homepage an, da ist auch ein Link drauf.
Mal hören, was es für Fragen gibt. Chaosradio hier, hallo, wer ist da? Timo, der dir gerade die E-Mail geschrieben hat?
Nein, ich habe eine Frage zu NetScape.
Ich bin NetScape-frei mit T-Online und habe mir schon immer überlegt, ob das NetScape Informationen von meinem Rechner mit versenden kann.
Zum Beispiel innerhalb der Festplatte, oder?
Seid ihr alle auf Funktelefon? Du klingst auch grausam. Telekom, Telekom, Telekom. Also die Frage, um es mal zu wiederholen... Hast du dein Radio an? Na ja, das rauscht trotzdem, aber egal. Ist ja nicht deine Schuld. Oder ihr müsst euch wieder Telefone mit Drehten dran holen. Die Frage ist, ob NetScape Informationen über den Rechner, den ich benutze, ins Netz wohin auch immer senden kann. Also ob irgendjemand über NetScape Zugriff auf meine Daten hat.
Ja, also NetScape selber sendet eigentlich keine bis gar keine, also so fast keine also annähernd keine Informationen über dich selber heraus. Allerdings ist ja seit NetScape 2.0 das Programm durch sogenannte Plugins zu erweitern. Und das wird auch derzeit sehr heftig getan. Zwei Sachen sind da vor allem zu erwähnen. Da ist zunächst einmal Java und JavaScript. Das sind Programmiersprachen, die besonders für die Benutzung im Internet entwickelt wurden. In Kürze sieht es halt so aus, mit den Webseiten, die man sich anschaut, werden auch, ohne dass man das groß steuern kann, wohl aber verhindern kann, Programme direkt in NetScape, in das Programm auf den eigenen Computer geladen und dort ausgeführt. Das ist natürlich zunächst einmal was sehr Kritisches. Es wird behauptet, dass diese Programme keinen Zugriff auf das System bekommen können. Das ist allerdings einfach nicht wahr. Es geht schon. Bei Java ist es da ein besonderes Problem. Java kann noch sehr viel mehr Eigendynamik entwickeln als zum Beispiel nur JavaScript, was in der Regel nur innerhalb deines Browsers Informationen auskundschaften kann. Aber auch da wurden schon Inhaltsverzeichnisse der Festplatte und ähnliches herausgefunden. Teilweise wurden auch Zugriff auf interne Schlüssel geliefert. Das sind so Fehler, die relativ schnell bekannt werden, die dann meistens auch von Netscape behoben werden. Und auch von den anderen Browser-Herstellern, die andere Probleme haben. Nur, das hört ja nie auf mit diesen Fehlern. Die wird es immer geben und durch die Plugins kriegt das Ganze jetzt eine Eigendynamik, die Netscape selber auch gar nicht mehr steuern kann. Eine andere Technologie, die gerade jetzt in den letzten zwei, drei Tagen wieder ins Rampenlicht gekommen ist, ist diese ActiveX-Geschichte von Microsoft, die im Internet Explorer eingebaut ist. Und es steht zu befürchten, dass sie auch in Netscape und andere Systeme kommt. Mit ActiveX wird im Prinzip direkter Programmcode ohne so eine Übersetzungsstufe noch dazwischen wie bei Java direkt auf den Computer heruntergeladen. Und Sicherheitsmechanismen gibt es eigentlich de facto nicht, sondern das basiert nur auf so einem Vertrauensprinzip. Du vertraust also per se vorher diesem Programm, was da über das Netz angeschossen kommt und auf Basis, weil irgendjemand gesagt hat, dass das wohl ganz sicher ist. Und da gibt es auch so Zertifikate, aber das ist nur ein Vertrauensding. Und wenn das Programm halt erstmal da ist, kann es im Prinzip tun und lassen, was es will. Das macht die Sache für Programmierer natürlich sehr viel einfacher, weil sie keine großen neuen Architekturen brücksichtigen müssen, sondern so weiter programmieren, wie sie es vorher unter Windows auch gemacht haben. Aber für Benutzer stellt das eine große Gefahr dar.
War das erstmal so ein kurzer Überblick?
Ich dachte, ich meinte jetzt eigentlich, das mit Java und ActiveX, das kannte ich schon. Ich meine jetzt, ob der NetScape von sich aus...
Wie ich sage, NetScape selber schickt nicht sehr viel. Im Wesentlichen das, was du in diese Voreinstellungsfenster, deine E-Mail-Adresse, deinen Namen und so, das sind Informationen, die teilweise auch schon mit jedem Klick übertragen werden. Da muss man sich wirklich darüber im Klaren sein.
Aber von deiner Festplatte jetzt irgendwelche Daten nicht?
Genau.
Naja, sagen wir...
Ja, kannst du, aber dann kannst du keine Mail aus NetScape schicken. Na ja gut, deswegen, klar, du kannst da gar nichts eingeben auch.
Du kannst Mail aus NetScape schicken, aber du kriegst dann die Antwort nicht.
Ja, sagen wir, NetScape kann im Prinzip keine Daten hinausgeben. NetScape ist auch in C geschrieben und C-Programmierer haben das Problem, dass sie alle Hände voll mit der Sprache zu tun haben, statt sich auf das Problem zu konzentrieren. So kommt es, dass bestimmte Strings unter Umständen eine bestimmte feste Länge haben. Wenn diese Länge überschritten wird, wird Code in den Stack geschrieben und es kann dazu führen, dass man von außen ein Textring hinsendet, zum Beispiel eine Liste von digitalen Datentypen für den Server, oder so etwas ähnliches, und dass dabei der Buffer überschrieben wird und Programmcode direkt in Netscape reingeschrieben wird und danach ausgeführt wird. Das klingt sehr theoretisch, sehr kompliziert. Es gibt aber tatsächlich Leute, die sowas implementiert haben. Ich würde mir das selber nicht zutrauen, das ist echt schwierig.
So hat auch schon der Internetwarm funktioniert auf dieser Basis, muss man dazu sagen. Also wirklich keine neue Geschichte. Es funktioniert aber immer noch auch mit Akku.
Das ist also ein Problem, das so ziemlich alle Programme haben. Auch Netzgip könnte davon betroffen sein.
Okay, danke dir erstmal. Die Telefone sind teilweise grausam. Ich habe sehr viel E-Mail. Ich würde sagen, wir machen kurz Stichpunkte, schreiben die auf, die E-Mails durch, dann telefonieren wir nochmal, vielleicht fallen da Sachen zusammen. Einmal schreibt der große Adler, Eagle nämlich. Sollte euer Gespräch noch zu Cookies im BBW kommen, dann erklärt bitte mal, ob es möglich ist, Cookies zu faken. Also einfach durch IPs-Boofing ganz viele verschiedene zu schicken. Und erklärt bitte auch, dass es zwei Arten von Cookies gibt. Nämlich einmal Only Send Back to Itself. Die sind voll für Banners. Und welche, die auf die Platte in Cookies Text gemacht werden. Übrigens zeige ich den Eindruck, seitdem ich meine Cookie-Datei geschützt habe, also nicht beschreibbar gemacht habe, dass mein Netzgeld öfter abstürzt. Kann das sein? Eigentlich nicht, ne?
Na ja, was soll man dazu sagen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Klar kann das sein, aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay, dann ist es doch mein Escape. Ich lasse natürlich nicht auf den Rechner kommen, ist klar. Nächste Frage. Ich wollte mal fragen, ob es legal ist, Serial Numbers und Red Codes für Programme, besonders Shareware, ohne die dazugehörigen Programme anzubieten und zu ziehen. Freedom of Speech. Gibt es Chaosradio regelmäßig? Gruß an Johnny, danke. Ja, gibt es jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Servus, in der Firma, in der ich jobbe, gegen eine Mail rum, dass es einen Internetvirus gebe, der via Mail wirkt. Angeblich soll dieser beim Lesen der Mail die Festplatte löschen. Ist es möglich, auf meinem Rechnerdienungsrechnerprogramme ausführen zu lassen via E-Mail? Was wird denn davon wem ausgeführt? Wie kommt eine Mail zu Rudrechten? Das schreiben wir jetzt erstmal auf, alles bevor was. Schreibt ihr mit? Letter hier und Leser und Schreier. Kann es sein, dass wenn man über ein Proxy geht, der Request nicht unbedingt an den WWW-Server weitergegeben wird, weil die intern gecashten Sites genommen werden? Das ist auch eine gute Frage, ja. Bleibt das im Cash oder geht es doch an den angewählten Rechner? Zum Vergleichen bestimmt, ne?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob du das richtig verstanden hast. Kannst du das nochmal kurz?
Also, ob ich die Frage verstanden habe, wenn ich jetzt über ein Proxy laufe, wenn die Seiten da alle drauf sind schon, ob ich dann gar nicht erst zu dem angewählten Rechner gehe, sondern einfach im Proxy hängen bleibe.
Du gehst immer durch den Proxy zunächst einmal. Der Proxy entscheidet selber, ob er sich die Daten erst mal holen muss oder ob er sie halt schon hat oder ob er sie von einem anderen Proxy holt.
Dazu kann es sein, dass der Proxy guckt, ob die Daten noch so aktuell sind, wie das, was er hat. Aber das hat dann mit dem User nichts zu tun.
Ja, die Frage ist, dass der Request von mir nicht unbedingt an den BBWs zwar weitergeben wird.
Das ist richtig.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Der Webserver wird umstellt in kompletten Ruhe gelassen. Das ist auch die Regel der Proxys.
Super. Chaosradio funktioniert auf dem ERC übrigens. Was ist mit dem TKGE? Da kommen wir auch noch drauf. Neue Telekommunikationsgesetz in Deutschland. Ich bin über IP-Raw via ISDN an der TU-Berlin.de. Wenn man an diesem Satz jemand vor 10 Jahren gesagt hätte. Ich habe Linungslaufen und Browser hin und her. Habe öfters FTP länger stehen, Pollen-News etc. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich habe schon öfter mal eine TCP-IP-Verbindung stehen. Könnt ihr mir bitte mal Stichworte geben, wo man rechnerangreifbar ist?
Steht da auch was für ein Rechner? Da steht nur Linux.
Hi, nochmal was. Da gab es mal um 87 ein paar deutsche Hacker, die in den USA gehackt haben. Am Ende wurden sie mehr oder weniger geschnappt. Einer wurde von Inaba Tod gefunden. Die Geschichte kennen wir. Da ist die Frage, ob man da mal ein bisschen was zu erzählen kann. Da hatte ich übrigens mal eine ganze Sendung drüber. Drei Stunden über genau diese Geschichte.
Über den KGB-Hack.
Ja, aber das war vor drei Jahren, glaube ich.
Aber hatten wir das in den Legenden nicht schon mal?
Nee, das haben wir bisher immer ausgelassen.
Okay, dann kann ich da nachher drauf eingehen.
So, dann die Mucke, die ihr zwischendrin spielt, die zackt, dann legt ihr erstmal einen neuen Namen zu. Sich Igel nennen, aber keine moderne Musik hören wollen. Naja, finde ich voll gut. Und wenn Mucke dann irgendwelche coolen Mods... Mods?
Mods, das sind diese vom Amiga stammenden Soundfiles.
Super cool, unglaublich.
Klar, das wäre jetzt auch machen.
Das ist wirklich super cool, weil es ist im Prinzip das Internet-Komponiersystem.
Wir sollten mal anfangen, wenn wir Antworten da fragen.
Nee, ich wollte erst alle mails, damit wir die Stichpunkte haben. Wir können ja mal ein bisschen sammeln. Achso, gut, das war jetzt die, die wir gerade schon mal besprochen haben. Moment, nee, Microsoft. Gibt es Möglichkeiten, sich vor Microsoft, die bei Usern hacken, zu schützen? Also da gibt es diese Geschichte von wegen, dass Microsoft über die Anmeldung bei Microsoft Network Festplatteninhalte ausgelesen habe. Da müssen wir auch noch was zu sagen wahrscheinlich. Im Zusammenhang mit der Hackerethik sollte die auch so nette Leute wie zum Beispiel Kim Schmitz erwähnen. Erwähnt bitte auch die unbemerkten Massenhacks. Bei der Installation von Windows-Programmen werden ungefragt Verzeichnisse erstellt. Also genau dasselbe. Eine weitere Unsätze ist das ungefragte Löschen von Netscape-Einstellungen beim Ausprobieren neuer Provider. Ja, das sind jetzt erstmal so die Stichpunkte. Das ist eine ganze Menge. Lass uns die jetzt erstmal so stehen lassen. Lass uns noch ein, zwei Anrufe nehmen und dann diese ganzen Sachen beantworten. Ich glaube, es ist besser, wenn wir Fragen sammeln, ja? Hallo, Chaosradio hier. Bernhard, pass auf, wir machen es mit dir auch so. Wenn du jetzt nicht eine Sache hast, wo du noch ein paar Mal nachfragen musst, lass uns die Frage auch so hier aufschreiben und dann versuchen wir alles zu beantworten.
Okay, meine Frage ist, es bieten sich ja zunehmend die Banken im Internet an irgendwie. Das weiß ich, Bank 24 zum Beispiel. Wie sicher ist das Ganze mit diesem TAN und PIN oder vielleicht ein Scrambleer zwischen Modem und Computer oder so?
Also diese Frage Internetbanking haben wir ja auch groß auf dem Zettel. Wie sicher sowas ist, werden wir auf alle Fälle beantworten.
Andere Fragen könnt ihr mich auf die Liste auf die C-Base setzen.
Achso, ja genau, wunderbar. Dann musst du kurz dranbleiben, ich brauch deinen ganzen Namen dann. Bleib einmal bereit. Genau, für die C-Base haben wir nämlich auch noch Karten am nächsten Dienstag. Wer da hin will, muss das immer dazu sagen. Ich bin völlig im Stress hier. Hallo, wer ist da?
Ich hab nur eine kurze Frage, kam nicht so raus beim Gespräch.
Ein Proxy kann man doch auch einfach ausschalten, ne?
Ja, unter Netscape, das ist in den Einstellungen.
Und dann hat man es doch eigentlich umgangen.
Ja, aber dann hast du wieder das Problem, dass es unter Umständen alles sehr langsam ist. Weil so ein Proxy kann schon wirklich eine bedeutende Disleunigung bedeuten.
Ich meine, wenn du Wert drauf legst, dass du...
Du kannst das grundsätzlich ausschalten, dann stellst du sicher, dass du immer direkt den Weg machst. Das Problem ist, dass du allerdings... Also bei Proxys hast du manchmal noch den Vorteil, dass du auch Informationen von deiner Webseite bekommst, die gerade unten ist, weil da halt noch die Daten im Cache liegen. Also man sollte so ein bisschen hin und her schalten. Das geht bei Netzgebiet leider nicht so einfach. Das wäre eigentlich ganz schön, dass man auch mit mehreren Proxys arbeiten kann.
Aber man geht trotzdem durch den Proxy durch und kann ja da auch irgendwie das Überwachen aufbesuchen. Weil man muss ja trotzdem eigentlich durch.
Nee, wenn du den Proxy nicht benutzt, gehst du auch nicht durch.
Genau.
Also wenn du keinen eingetragen hast, dann weiß der auch nichts von dir. Aber wenn du einen eingetragen hast, dann kriegt er wirklich jeden Request vollständig mit.
Den kriegt aber der Internetprovider sowieso. Also wenn der Proxy beim Internetprovider steht, dann ist es egal.
Na gut, hat man nichts gewonnen. Ja, könnt ihr mich auch auf die Liste setzen?
Bleibst du auch kurz am Telefon?
Ja, mach ich.
Bis gleich. So, da ich nur zwei Leute auf Telefonleitung legen kann, kurz ein bisschen Musik und dann erst mal... dann noch ein, zwei Anrufe und dann beantworten wir die Fragen.
Wir sind zuerst. Wir sind zuerst.
Wir sind jetzt noch so zwei kurze Anfragen noch und dann werden erstmal die Fragen beantwortet. Weil wenn wir jetzt einzeln reden, ich glaube dann wird das alles zu lang werden. Da hat auch eine ganze Menge Probleme noch zu lösen. Und wir sind ja hier die Problemlöser.
Hi, ich hab kurz eine eigentlich recht einfache Frage. Und zwar wir verschicken in der Firma halt übers Internet mit dem Programm Eudora E-Mails, wo wir dann als Attachments dann kleine Software-Pakete ranbatschen halten.
Mit Macintosh.
Und jetzt interessiert mich mal, was passiert mit, also ich weiß, dass Chaos irgendwie im Internet rumfährt, vorne steht eine Autonummer dran, und dann greift sich das derjenige, der das kriegen soll. Was passiert mit diesen, also wir verschicken halt kleine Datenmengen halt. Können diese Datenmengen von jemanden anders auch genutzt werden?
Also eine Mail mit einem Attachment ist eine Mail, die aus verschiedenen Teilen besteht. Das kann halt auch eine Datei sein oder auch ein Bild. Zunächst einmal ist es grundsätzlich für alle Mails, die du übers Internet schickst, wenn sie nicht mit PGP oder anderen Verfahren explizit verschlüsselt wurden, kann jeder, der sie weiterleitet, und das sind im Grunde sehr, sehr viele, im Prinzip mitlesen. Wenn also jemand gezielt an deiner Internetleitung sitzt, das ist natürlich schon etwas schwieriger, so dann könnt ihr also auch konsequent alles überwachen. Was überhaupt erstmal das Internet betritt? Wenn ihr das in der Firma untereinander macht, ist das was anderes.
Nee, nee, wir schicken das ins Ausland, als ich das nach Singapur oder England.
Genau, also das ist alles überwachbar. Ihr solltet euch keine Kreditkarten schicken, keine Kreditkartennummern, keine geschäftsinternen Dinge, da solltet ihr wirklich sehr vorsichtig sein und lieber darüber nachdenken, so ein Verschlüsselungssystem einzuführen. Die Sache mit den Attachments läuft so. Eudora kann erkennen, dass es sich dabei um eine Datei handelt und legt die auf der Festplatte als Datei ab. Nein, also in dem Moment beim Provider auch. Das gehört, ist zunächst einmal ein Bestandteil der Mail, wie der Text, den du liest, auch. Und wenn es bei dir ankommt, dann schaut sich Eudora das an, aha, das besteht aus verschiedenen Teilen, zeigt dir den Text an und diese Attachments, diese Dateien werden als solche auf der Festplatte abgelegt. Wenn es sich dabei um Programme handelt, startet Eudora die allerdings nicht automatisch. Kann nun natürlich jetzt auch wieder kommen mit irgendwie Fehlern in Eudora und so, dass es irgendwann mal einen Weg gibt, wie diese Programme automatisch gestartet werden können. Eine andere Frage, die wir vorhin hatten, ging nämlich genau in die gleiche Richtung, Mailvirus. Da bezieht sich, glaube ich, der Mail-Schreiber auf den Fall, der bei Lotus Notes bekannt geworden ist, dass eben bei Lotus Notes das eben nicht so ist, dass das nicht gleich ausgeführt wird, sondern er hatte eben die Möglichkeit dort so was direkt auszuführen und sich entsprechend Informationen zurückschicken zu lassen. Also die Frage... Ich finde die Teil nicht so darüber informiert.
Die Frage am Telefon jetzt, kann man auch dieses Attachment abfangen? Prinzipiell ja.
Aber das können, wie gesagt, eigentlich nur die Leute, die Provider oder der Provider oder über die Computer, die das...
Genau, aber das sind halt viele, weil jeder, der am Internet teilnimmt, leitet unter Umständen. Also natürlich der normale Privatanwender nicht so, aber jede größere Firma, und umso größer sie wird, umso eher, leitet das weiter. Teilweise werden ganze Bereiche des Internets, also wirklich weltum spannende Bereiche von einer einzelnen Firma betrieben, IBM und Microsoft mittlerweile natürlich auch, sodass auch dort Datenpakete sehr lange und teilweise eben auch fast ausschließlich sich nur in den Bereich dieses einen Anbieters bewegen. Das ist ein ähnliches.
Wenn die Terminellen, ich weiß nicht was, bestreben haben, dann können die sagen, wir schaufeln uns auch mal die Daten schnell auf unsere Platten.
Genau, die, die bei uns durchgehen, die ziehen wir uns schnell mal ab.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob da was braucht für eures Leiber.
Weil man in der Praxis natürlich, also außer ihr fallt jetzt auf durch zum Beispiel viele Attachments, die bei euch rausgehen über den Account und die, weiß ich nicht, wo man sich denkt, was verschicken die denn da immer, wenn die Mails jedes Mal einen Megabyte groß sind, dann in der Praxis ist das natürlich ein ziemlicher Aufwand. Also man muss schon aufwenden. Mails abzufangen von Providern ist eigentlich relativ nötig.
Aber es gibt natürlich Organisationen, wie zum Beispiel die NSA in den USA, also National Security Agency, die grundsätzlich für Überwachungen abhören, zuständig ist. Die hat sehr große Rechner im Internet und ist auch sehr nah an großen Netzwerkbetreibern dran. In den USA ist ja sowieso alles etwas offener. Also davon ausgegangen werden kann, dass viele Informationen, die heute über das Internet gehen, weil aber nicht alle, aber eben schon sehr viele, von automatischen Programmen untersucht werden und auf Schlüsselwörter abgetastet werden, genauso wie das jahrzehntelang im Telefonnetz auch stattgefunden hat. Also wir erleben jetzt auf dem Internet exakt dasselbe wie auf dem Telefonnetz, nur dass die Dimensionen halt ganz andere sind.
Kannst du mir nur kurz sagen oder kann mir einer von euch kurz sagen, wie man solche Programme nennt, die jetzt Attachments und... Letzteren ist es für uns wichtiger, dass die Attachments halt, die Dateien, die wir verschicken, dass die eben nicht irgendjemand benutzt, der dafür nicht bezahlt hat.
Wie gesagt, das Attachment ist Bestandteil deiner Mail, wie der Text auch. Das heißt, wenn du die Mail über das Internet verschickst, mit einem Attachment, dann kann das Attachment genauso vollständig abgefangen und abgespeichert und untersucht werden, wie der Text, den du liebst.
Meine Frage war jetzt aber, wie schützt man sich davor?
Wie halten sich diese Programme, die irgendwas verschlüsseln haben?
Genau. Das war die Frage, da gibt es ein Programm, das halt wirklich gut ist. Das ist PGP, das haben wir vorhin schon mal erwähnt.
Und da gibt es auch mittlerweile eine Implementation für Mac für, die heißt Safe Mail, gibt es auch www.highware.com.
Ja, es gibt auch schon immer Mac PGP. PGP als frei erhältliche Softwareprodukt findest du leicht im Internet, wenn du nur Yahoo, PGP, da wirst du alles darüber finden, was du brauchst. Und kannst auch für deinen... Also www.yahoo kennst du, ne? Und dort nach PGP in deren Verzeichnis suchen, da findest du also ausreichend Hinweise, wo du diese Software bekommst. Genau. Freeware sogar. Keine Shareware.
Und die Mac-Implementation, die es jetzt gibt, eine etwas neuere, die etwas leichter zu benutzen ist, heißt Safe Mail.
Die ist aber kommerziell.
Ich verstehe das so schlecht. Wie heißt die bitte?
Safe Mail, also wie sichere Mail, Safe Mail.
Safe Mail, alles klar.
Die ist echt gut.
Okay, gut, dann sag ich erst mal recht her, vielen Dank.
Danke dir. Ich habe da noch eine weiterführende Frage zu dem Thema. Wenn ich ein Attachment als entpackende Datei verschlüssel auf dem Mac jetzt und die mit einem Passwort schütze, also ich kann ja so mit, weiß ich nicht, Stafford oder so ein Kram, kann ich ja Passwortabfragen machen.
Also für Stafford gibt es zum Beispiel ein Programm, was dieses Passwort wieder raus hobelt auf dem Netz.
Okay, nehmen wir an, es gäbe eins für die es das nicht gibt. Dann schreibt es einer. Ja, aber die Frage, die ich stelle, wenn ich das als Attachement schicke, ist doch auch relativ sicher, oder? Also ist einfach noch mal eine zusätzliche Sicherheit?
Nicht sehr sicher, würde ich sagen. Zunächst einmal ist ein Stafford Archive auch sehr einfach als solches zu erkennen. Und da gerade bei diesem weltbekannten Dateiformater gibt es jetzt schon massenhaft Software, die da aktiv drauf losgeht. Also man muss, wenn man Verschlüsselungen macht, darauf Wert legen, dass man es wirklich mit einer sehr guten Verschlüsselungssoftware macht. Und nicht nur irgendwas, wo noch ein Passwort drin ist oder so. Das reicht einfach nicht. Es muss sich wirklich um Verschlüsselungen handeln, dass das, was da rauskommt, nicht lesbar ist.
Wollen wir erstmal, wir machen es jetzt schon wieder anders, wollen wir erstmal noch ein paar Fragen sammeln?
Wir haben gleich so viele, dass wir die Stunde damit vollkriegen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall so die nächste halbe Stunde wollte ich dann schon mit der Beantwortung vollkriegen. Hi, Johnny hier und der Chaos Computer Club.
Ich habe keine konkrete Frage.
Würde aber sehr gern zur Web-Crash-Party.
Könntest du mich dafür?
Kann ich machen. Bleibst du kurz dran? Ich stelle dich raus und da schreiben wir dann deinen Namen auf. Das können wir jetzt so auch machen, klar. Hi, Chaosradio.
Ich stolpere immer mal über diesen DNS-Entry.
Ich würde eigentlich gern mal wissen, was das bedeutet.
Also, dass man da nicht reinkommt.
Und manchmal kommt man auch auf den Teil.
Also, du arbeitest mit Netzgab und kriegst entsprechende Fehlermeldungen, dass der DNS-Entry nicht gefunden wurde. Richtig. DNS steht für Domain Name System. Und das ist die Technologie, die im Internet verwendet wird, um diese Namen, die man immer eintippt, www, irgendwas, in die tatsächlichen Adressen des Internets, den sogenannten Internet- oder IP-Adressen, umzusetzen. Das sind diese Zahlen mit den Punkten dazwischen. Weil der Name alleine reicht dem Netz nicht aus, um den Weg zu finden. Deswegen fragt man einen sogenannten DNS-Server, gib mir die Adresse für diesen Namen. Und wenn dieser Server, wenn dieses Programm nicht in der Lage ist, diese Adresse zu finden, dann gibt es diese Fehlermeldung. Das ist eine sehr technische Fehlermeldung. Da merkt man auch noch, wie groß die Kluft zwischen Programmierern und Anwendern ist. In der Regel bedeutet das, dass es entweder von dir falsch eingetippt wurde, dass es diesen Namen wirklich nicht gibt, oder dass er eben derzeit nicht gefunden werden kann, weil das nicht richtig konfiguriert ist, das nicht richtig funktioniert, oder jemand was falsch gemacht hat, oder weil der Rechner gerade unten ist, oder jemand die Datenbank gelöscht hat, oder was auch immer. Also darüber brauchst du dich gar nicht groß aufzuregen. Das bedeutet nur, dass du da jetzt gerade nicht rankommst.
Na, ich hab's etwas gemerkt.
Manchmal ging's und manchmal ging's nicht.
Siehst du, so ne Fragen mag ich. Konkrete Fragen, konkrete Antworten. Okay, wir lassen, wir beantworten jetzt gleich erstmal diese Fragen. Ihr werdet in der letzten halben Stunde noch Zeit haben, euch auf die Gästeliste setzen zu lassen. Die ist immer jetzt irgendwann voll. Wenn ihr nur für die Gästeliste anruft, dann ruft jetzt während wir die Fragen beantworten weiter an. Und ich werd gucken, dass das draußen dann gemacht wird, damit wir hier ein bisschen Luft kriegen, okay? Zum Fragen stellen also nicht anrufen, sondern nur für die Gästeliste. Die ist irgendwann voll. Natürlich sag's dann durch, wenn sie voll ist.
Ja Die Einmeldung kommt am Schluss, aber jetzt fang mal an.
Nee, nee, nee, lass mich das erstmal durchlesen.
Mach mal was wir reden.
Ja, lass uns überreden heißt der Chaosradio. Also ganz kurz, das Problem, was wir im Moment haben, ist, dass wir telefonisch und per E-Mail von... die Mails beantworten, beziehungsweise der Chaos Computer Club wird dies tun und ansonsten, wenn ihr weitere Fragen dazu habt, guckt euch wirklich im Netz auch selber um. Also nehmt diese Sachen hier als Stichworte, es ist sehr, sehr leicht Infos darüber zu bekommen und da auch an Universitäten, von Hackern oder von Zeitungen wirklich viel zu lesen im Netz selber. Es gibt verschiedene Suchmaschinen im Internet unter www, also z.B. www.yahoo.com oder lykos.com und viele weitere und da reicht eine Stichworteingabe und man hat mehrere Tage zu tun. Aber wir versuchen natürlich trotzdem viele Fragen hier zu beantworten. Und jetzt News oder was?
Nein, lass uns erst noch mal ein... Willst du noch sammeln? Wir sammeln jetzt mal zu Ende und dann beantworten wir das.
Aber jetzt machen wir diese Gästelisten Aktion. Ich dachte, wir beantworten jetzt.
Ja, dann beantworten wir. Dann haben wir die Sachen mit den Cookies, die war da auf dem Tisch.
Genau.
Ja, also die Cookies sind ein bisschen viel gehypt worden in letzter Zeit. Im Prinzip handelt es sich dabei um nichts wirklich dolle Gefährliches. Wenn man sich zu einem Webserver connectet, hinterlässt man sowieso eine IP-Adresse und meistens genügend Daten, damit man erkennen kann, wer, also wenn zehn Seiten abgerufen wurden, die einem User zuzuordnen, ohne zu wissen, welcher User das ist. Also man kann sozusagen Gruppenbilden von abrufen und die einem bestimmten User zuordnen. Und was die Cookies machen, ist im Prinzip nichts anderes, nur dass es auf einer technisch einfachen Basis passiert. Man kann mit Cookies weder den Inhalt der Festplatte auslesen, noch irgendwelche privaten Daten eines Users ins Netz schicken. Man kann damit auch nicht feststellen, wie sich der User durchs Netz klickt, sondern lediglich wie er lokal einen Server benutzt. Und das könnte man auch ohne Cookies.
Und das muss auch nicht immer nur schlecht sein.
Das ist mitunter auch praktisch.
Das ist der Einkaufswagen im Web. Zum Thema Cookies ist es trotzdem sehr spannend und witzig teilweise, wenn man sich dieses Cookie-File mal anguckt. Auf dem Mac ist es sehr einfach. Da liegt es im Netscape-Verzeichnis. Heißt dann auch, glaube ich, cookie.txt oder sowas?
Im Cache-Verzeichnis.
Im Cache-Verzeichnis oder, nee, ich glaube, im Preferences-Verzeichnis unter Netscape. Wie auch immer. Also man findet das unter Windows. Liegt es wahrscheinlich im 500. Unterverzeichnis mit Namen XLQ oder keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Da heißt es da ein Rissending-Kumpen-Punkt.
Lass mal die Windows in dir sagen.
Ja, ich werde nur ein bisschen stecken.
Wir haben noch ein paar schöne Hacks von Windows hier.
Okay, Cookies, also kurz. Ach so, und was war das mit zwei verschiedene Arten von Cookies?
Ja, es gibt da die Möglichkeit, diese Cookies persistent in einem Fall zu schreiben, sodass nicht nur beim nächsten Klick, sondern auch das nächste Mal, wenn man Netscape startet, dieses Cookie noch geschickt wird.
Aber das ist auch nicht gefährlicher deswegen.
Nee, ist nur anders.
Eine Antwort. Ah, gibt's zwei, aber das ist nur anders.
Ja, das ist auch nicht wirklich wichtig. Lass uns da nicht weiter drüber reden.
Gut, dann gibt's noch die nächste Frage. Ich glaube, die kann man gar nicht richtig beantworten, ob es legal ist, Seriennummern von Shareware-Geschichten irgendwie rüber zu blasen.
Da hieß es im Wesentlichen Shareware, in Wirklichkeit meinte, aber natürlich Seriennummern von geklauten Programmen.
Das hat er aber nicht gesagt.
Hat er geschrieben.
Darum geht das im Wesentlichen. Es gibt jetzt Server im World Wide Web, wo man solche Seriennummern findet, um sich ein Programm freizuschalten, das man nicht legal erworben hat. Auch hier gilt natürlich wieder erstmal der gesunde Menschenverstand.
Und außerdem die Straßenverkehrsordnung.
Wenn du das benutzt, dann ist das natürlich verboten. Wenn du die Seriennummer da eintippst und damit illegalerweise dieses Programm benutzt, dann ist das einfach verboten. Das ist der Punkt. So, dann hatten wir...
Ach so, das hatten wir schon.
Nee, nee, nee, Nee. Mail-Viren hatten wir noch nicht. Es ging dabei darum, ob man mit Mails Programme oder irgendetwas dahin verschicken kann und die da zur Ausführung kriegt. Und das geht natürlich zumindest mit Makros. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Attachment als ein Work-File mit einem integrierten Makro als Attachment schicke und es dann noch schaffe, dass der User auf der anderen Seite dieses Word-File auch anschaut, dann wird das Makro selbstverständlich ausgeführt und damit kann man richtig Unfug machen.
Also das ist sozusagen die Möglichkeit, Programme zu schmuggeln, der Benutzer denkt, es handelt sich um eine Text-Datei, also für eben so eine Textverarbeitung, die aber auch so Skriptfunktionen erlaubt. Und dann wird eben mit dem Text gleichzeitig, der Text kann sich um irgendetwas drehen und das Programm um was ganz anderes, das dann eben gleichzeitig mit dem Betrachten des Textes gestartet wird, setzt aber voraus, das muss man schon sagen, dass man dieses Attachment dann in ein Programm eben reinlädt. Also es ist nicht einfach, das Betracht reinzulegen.
Wenn dir einer ein Word-Dokument schickt, dann klickst du es einfach an.
Das tu ich nicht.
Ja, es gibt aber noch einen anderen Weg. Zumindest bei Microsoft Windows MT gibt es noch einen weiteren Weg, dieses Ding wirklich zur Ausführung zu bringen, nämlich durch eine Unsicherheit in der Entwicklungsumgebung Visual C++. Da gibt es ein Programm, das nennt sich p-view.exe. Wenn man das ausführt, dann kann man zumindest, wenn man über Netbios mit diesem NT-Rechner verbunden ist, ihnen veranlassen, diese Dok-Datei oder Irgendwie-Datei, egal wie dieses Attachment jetzt heißt, auch wenn es sich dabei nicht um Word, sondern um ein anderes Programm handelt, auszuführen, indem man es einfach mit einem ausführbaren Programm verknüpft. Also so, dass jede Textdatei automatisch dieses Programm ausführt. Das kann man eben darüber vorgeickeln, über dieses Programm P-View, also Process View, mit dem man da Modifikationen vornehmen kann.
Wann machen wir eigentlich die Sendung Warum ich keine Microsofts aufwende?
Die machen wir doch ständig.
Also Entschuldigung. Gut, dann war die nächste Frage.
Bei den Attachments muss man natürlich, um vielleicht noch kurz Einsatz dazu zu sagen, muss man darauf achten, dass wenn man Programme geschickt kriegt, also wenn dahinter Excel steht oder bei Mac dann irgendwie ersichtlich ist, dass es nicht eine Textartal ist oder so, wenn man die ausführt, hat man natürlich ein Problem eventuell. Besonders wenn das von jemanden kommt, den man nicht kennt. Oft gibt es zum Beispiel in Newsgroups, gibt es dann irgendwie so ganz tolle Angebote oder Leute sagen, wir machen eine Umfrage oder irgendwie sowas. Und darauf zu antworten bedeutet, man zeigt Interesse an einem bestimmten Thema. Und eventuell wird man dann entweder mit Werbemail bombardiert oder da sind dann irgendwelche Attachments dran. Wer die ausführt, der muss vorsichtig sein.
Gut, nächste Fragekomplex war zum Telekommunikationsgesetz. Und da wird es jetzt ein bisschen verloren. Also das Telekommunikationsgesetz tritt ja am 01.01.98 in Kraft und ist prinzipiell eben dafür da, wenn ja sozusagen jedes Unternehmen in der monopolefreien Umgebung Telekommunikation Dienstleistung anbieten kann, eben wie das geregelt ist. Und da gibt es etliche problematische Geschichten, die aber ineinander verschachtelt sind. Also das Telekommunikationsgesetz selbst zum Beispiel hat einen Riesenhammer im Paragraph 90, der eben besagt, dass die sogenannte Regulierungsbehörde, das ist also der Nachfolger des jetzigen Bundespostministeriums, Regulierungsbehörde heißt das denn für alle, also für Mannesmann, für Wevacom, für Telekom und so fort, die darf also im Auftrag der Geheimdienste, der Bedarfsträger, wie es so schön heißt, der Polizei und so fort, muss die einen Zugriff auf alle Kundendateien haben, derjenigen, die Telekommunikationsdienstleistung für andere erbringen. Also zum Beispiel auch Internet Service Provider, Telefongesellschaften, genauso wie Mobilfunkanbieter und so fort. Und der besondere Trick ist, dass diejenigen, die also dieser Regulierungsbehörde diese Schnittstelle zur Verfügung stellen müssen, wo die eben die Kundendatei ablutschen können, die dürfen die Abfragen nicht feststellen. Es ist ihnen bei Gefängnisstrafe verboten, festzustellen, wenn da jemand versucht, die Kundendatei rauszulüssen. Das kann man sich so einfach vorstellen, wie die staatlich verordnete Lizenz zum Hacken oder so ähnlich. Also wenn sozusagen ein Systembetreiber sich strafbar macht, zu gucken, ob da ein Hacker drin ist, dann können die Hacker sich wirklich nur noch gegenseitig freuen. Weil das ist sozusagen das Paradies in dem Sinne. Aber ich glaube, das ist also einer der Paragraphen. Eine andere Geschichte ist die, dass im Rahmen dieser neuen Gesetzgebung gibt es denn noch das IUKDIG, das Informationskommunikationsdienstegesetz. Das also vom Bundesforschungsministerium, vom Minister rückwärts, Zukunftsminister rückwärts da verabschiedet wird. Und das wiederum impliziert mit einem Umweg über das TKG, die sogenannte TDSV, die Telekommunikations-Informationsdienstleistungsunternehmensdatenschutzverordnung. Das bedeutet also, dass die Diensteanbieter, die Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen für andere erbringen, wiederum einer bestimmten Datenschutzgesellschaft unterließen. Und da stehen zum Beispiel so Sachen drin, wie das in dem § 7 Absatz 2 oder irgendwie sowas, dass also wenn ein Telekommunikationsdienstleistungsanbieter einen Verdacht auf Missbrauch hat, also Missbrauch von Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen, dann darf er nicht nur die Vermittlungsdaten, sondern auch die Inhaltsdaten aufwerten. Also auf gut deutsch, die Telekom darf Leute abhören ohne richterliche Genehmigung und ohne, dass es jetzt irgendwie die Polizei abhört, sondern die Telekom selbst, wenn sie also den Verdacht hat, dass jemand Telekommunikationsanschlüsse missbraucht. Wobei das noch nicht mal definiert ist, was überhaupt Missbrauch ist. Gut, dieses Ding ist noch nicht verabschiedet, aber so steht das da erstmal drin. Und damit könnten sie uns also sowieso pauschal, weil wir brauchen ja mindestens. Aber gut, also ich meine, ich glaube, diese Gesetze sind, ich sehe hier schon die Gesichter, wo es der Steckner einfach sind. Es gibt ja glaube ich mehrere Informationen ab und zu hier und da mal auf www.cccde.de Da mach ich ab und zu was zu. Und ansonsten bin ich wegen diesem Blödsinn morgen zum Beispiel mal wieder an Bonn und versuche, dass unseren Herrn Volksrepräsentanten schon...
Oh, Spitzchen und der Sekt vielleicht.
Hatte ihr mal schon das Fax von Frank gekriegt?
Ja. Gut, also lassen wir dieses Thema jetzt unter den Tisch fallen.
Genau, also diese Terminertrag.
Wir fragen dazu vielleicht auch lieber per Mail, also oder beim Internet.
Nächste Frage.
Waren...
Ey, die ganzen Amiga-Leute schreiben, dass die Musik scheiße sind.
Ja, dann sollen sie Mods schicken.
Dann sollen sie auch wirklich Mods schicken, denn wir haben auf unserem Chaosradio-Webseite auch schon immer den... Wir haben schon immer den Aufruf gehabt für das Chaosklavier, was wir hier schon mal gestartet haben, was dann irgendwie leidlich wieder entzogen wurde.
Und wer wollte das programmieren und bis wann sollte das fertig sein?
Na ja, du weißt nicht wie das ist.
Auf jeden Fall, ich habe genau einen Sound bisher bekommen. Und wenn ihr wirklich bessere Musik hören wollt und wenn es wirklich Mods sein sollen, dann schickt sie mir, dann werde ich sie auch in der nächsten Sendung schon abspielen, aber nicht mit einem Amiga, sondern mit einem anderen Kumpel.
Besser Musik brauchen wir nicht.
Besser Musik gibt es überhaupt nicht. Musik wird von uns ausgewählt.
Punkt.
Gut, nächste Frage.
Das ist im Falle das Schluss mit interaktiv hier.
Gut, also ich habe dann hier noch den Microsoft Registration Wizard auf dem Zettel. Genau.
Der war...
Das ist folgende Geschichte.
Ein Schnellschuss.
Na ja, ursprünglich hatte sich Microsoft ja festgestellt, vorgestellt, dass sich alle Leute nicht ans Internet etwa anschließen, sondern ans Microsoft-Network. Also an ein von Microsoft aufgebautes Netzwerk, das eben derart funktionieren sollte, dass man mit dem Betriebssystem, in diesem Fall Windows 95, auch gleich automatisch die Zugangssoftware hat. Die haben die Leute übrigens tatsächlich alle. Und in der ursprünglichen amerikanischen Version gab es da noch ein kleines Schmankerl, nämlich den Microsoft Registration Wizard. Das war also eine Software, die, wenn man sich erstmalig beim Microsoft-Netzwerk angemeldet hat und registriert hat, nebenbei noch Microsoft den gesamten Festplatteninhalt, also sozusagen, der übertragen hat, dass Microsoft danach wusste, welche Microsoft-Produkte sich alle auf der Festplatte des jeweiligen Kunden, die sie also mit Namen, Anschriften und so weiter und so fort hatten, drauf befinden, um dann eben abzugleichen, wie viele Produkte er davon überhaupt legal erworben hatte und für den Rest durch automatisch entweder eine Rechnung oder einen Anwalt loszuschicken. Und das war also selbst den Amerikanern, und Amerika ist nun schon ein Land, wo es Datenschutz eigentlich nicht gibt, also das war selbst denen etwas zu heftig, dass Microsoft sozusagen den Leuten gleich ganz direkt in die Brieftasche wollte mit diesem Netzwerk und den Umweg über die Produktoptions gar nicht mehr machte. So war das. So war das. Dann hatten wir hier noch... Was ist das? Ich hab hier noch vier Sachen.
Ich meine zum Registration Wizard, ich hab hier alles gesagt. Also da war noch eine Frage, er sei, meinte hier einer, das richtig erinnere, über IPRaw mit seinem Linux System am Internet und wie kann man das hacken?
Naja, ich nehme mal an, IPRaw bezieht sich auf den ISDN Übertragungsmodus. Also in erster Linie ist das halt eine ganz normale IP-Verbindung. Damit treten ganz normalen Unix-Sicherheitslücken in Kraft. Also da wären Sendmail-Probleme. Man sollte dafür sorgen, dass entweder gar kein Sendmail läuft oder zumindest die aktuelle Version oder vielleicht auch ein anderes Programm als Sendmail. Dann sollte man alles das, was man an Netzwerksservices nicht wirklich braucht, abschalten. Das heißt, man sollte NFS abschalten. Man sollte FTP abschalten, wenn man es nicht braucht. Man sollte vor allen Dingen die R-Sternchen-Services abschalten, R-Shell, R-Copy und so weiter. Und vielleicht sogar Telnet abschalten und dafür SSH installieren. SSH ist sowas wie eine Telnet-Verbindung mit PGP oben drauf. Das heißt, die ist auch verschlüsselt und identifiziert. Ähnlich wie das bei PGP funktioniert, nur dass man halt eine Telnet-Verbindung hat.
Bezieht sich natürlich auf die Server auf diesem Gerät und nicht auf die Programme, die man selbst benutzt, um auf andere Server zuzugreifen. Nur defaultmäßig installiert so in Linux die meisten Server und die muss man von Hand abschalten.
Also man sollte sich etc.rc.inet2 angucken.
Okay, dann hatten wir noch die kurze Anfrage, wie ist denn das? Ich installiere die Testsoftware für einen neuen Provider und schon sind meine ganzen Präferenzen weg. Naja, das ist, denke ich, ein gängiges Problem. Jeder Provider spricht natürlich seine Kunden so an, als wäre er das erste Mal überhaupt dabei, Internet auszuprobieren. Und typischerweise wird halt die Software so installiert, dass alles so ist, wie es sein soll. Und da wird also selten berücksichtigt, was schon da ist. Das ist einfach ein Problem der Software. Wie schnell sich das lösen wird, ist offen. Manche Systeme haben es einfacher, manche nicht. Alles wird besser. Ja, dann haben wir hier natürlich noch zwei große Posten. Banken und KGB, was nehmen wir denn da zuerst?
Ich würde sagen die KGB nehmen wir mal ruhig zuerst.
Wolltet ihr nicht sowieso mal eine Legenden-Sendung machen?
Hatten wir die nicht schon?
Aber das wird echt zu lang erst, glaube ich.
Dann sollte man kurz erwähnen, was hinter dem KGB-Hack steht.
Im Grunde genommen war es so, dass die Hacker-Szene damals aus vielen Leuten, die sich mehr oder weniger erkannten, bestand. Und einige halt einesseits auf die Idee kamen, man könnte damit auch Prole machen. Dann haben sie halt über ihren dubiosen Bekanntenkreis dubiose Kontakte aufgebaut genommen zu irgendwelchen Ostberliner Handelsniederlassungen sowjetischer Ministerien-Besagen, dem KGB. Und haben denen eben angeboten, Informationen aus Computern rauszuhacken und dafür Geld zu bekommen. Die haben zwar irgendwie nie richtig das geliefert, was die Russen haben wollten. Aber gut, lange Rede kurzer Sinn. Sie haben ihnen C-Compiler gegeben. Vor allem, der Trick ist halt, die haben sich für die ganzen Kennwortlisten überhaupt nicht interessiert. Die wollten Gottverdammte Cuts-Software und Chip-Layouts und irgendwelchen Industrie-Kram, für den sich kein Hack-Halter der Welt irgendwie richtig interessiert. Aber gut, lange Rede kurzer Sinn. Es ist Geld geflossen. Das Ganze war weder legal noch mit der Hacker-Ethik in irgendeiner Art und Weise irgendwie verdreht war. Und vor allem ist denen dann auch irgendwann klar geworden, dass sie sich da echt in eine Scheiße manövriert haben. Wir sagen, einer der Beteiligten zum Beispiel hatte irgendwie Knittungen unterschrieben, war Bargeld, das er empfangen hat und damit praktisch schon seine Straftaten quittiert und solche Geschichten. Und ein anderer Beteiligter an der Aktion war irgendwie durch das Geld dann auch in die Versuchung gekommen, Drogen zu nehmen, zu seinen Computersüchten dazu, was ihm auch nicht wirklich gut gekommen ist.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Wildzeitungs-Story.
Die klassische Wildzeitungs-Story. Und naja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Dann haben die Beteiligten teilweise kalte Füße bekommen und haben sich also überlegt, sie überoffenbaren sich doch jetzt vielleicht besser mal den Behörden, bevor diese es tun. Und es gab dann da eben Verhandlungen mehr oder weniger im Vorab über Rechtsanwälte, dass das irgendwie so laufen sollte, weil der eine war halt drogensüchtig geworden, dass der dann auch eine Therapie kriegt bei der Gelegenheit und dass er also fürs Grobe irgendwie gesorgt ist, dass die Leute nicht alle auf der Straße oder im Gefängnis sitzen, sondern dass das eben eine Kooperation ist und so fort. Blöderweise haben allerdings die Behörden in erster Linie waren die natürlich interessiert in den Antieninformationen, aber weniger daran, denen jetzt irgendwie groß entgegenzukommen. Beispielsweise wurde dem kokainsichtigen Hackwart, dem Karl Koch eben einen Heroinenplatz angewiesen. Das nützt ihm allerdings herzlich wenig, da er mittlerweile auf LSD hingeblieben war und irgendwie einen immensen Kokainverbrauch hat. Das hat mit Junkietum eigentlich nicht viel zu tun. Das ist einfach eine ganz andere Geschichte, die aber nicht minder durchgeknallt ist. Nun gut, die Legende ist nie richtig gekehrt worden. Wir sagen, dieser Karl Koch hat sich im Lauf von monatelangen Vernehmungen, die es gab, sowohl vom Verfassungsschutz als auch vom Bundeskriminalamt, mussten sich die Beteiligten dann so richtig mit der Lampe und dem guten und dem bösen Onkel und welchen Geschichten stellen. Das war ein immenser Druck. Dann wurden ihnen irgendwelche Scheinjobs zugewiesen, dass sie sich so eine Art durchgeleichte Existenz simulieren konnten. Und der Hackbar hat zumindest ein Stück weit nie wieder den Bezug zur Realität gefunden. Und er ist dann jedenfalls tot im Wald irgendwann aufgefunden worden.
Verbrannt?
Verbrannt, aufgefunden worden. Und das ist eine ziemlich scheiß Geschichte, wo noch eine Menge irgendwie, das kann man in drei Minuten nicht erläutern.
Aber so war das?
So war das. Und letztendlich ist es genauso plausibel, dass ihn irgendwelche Leute aus dem Weg räumen wollten, als auch genauso plausibel, dass er einfach keinen Boden mehr unter den Füßen gesehen hat.
Aber wir wissen die Geschichte.
Exakt. Also sozusagen, nichts ist sicher daran. Wen es interessiert, es gibt dazu eine Dokumentation, die CCC erhältlich, die kostet gerade mal 5 Mark, das sind über 100 Seiten, wo die Geschichte von Karl Koch dokumentiert ist und wo auch die Hintergründe sind.
An dieser Stelle dann kurz einmal den Radiotäkern nochmal durchsagen und dann vielleicht auch die normale Snellmail-Adresse für alle Leute.
Also, wen diese Doku oder auch unsere allgemeinen Materialien interessieren, da schickt am besten mal 5 Mark in Briefmarken an den CCC in der Schwenkheystraße 85 in 20255 Hamburg. Das klagen wir am Ende der Sendung auch nochmal.
Und ich werde auch Informationen zu der Karl-Koch-Dokumentation schicken mit dem Chaosradio-Ticker. Schickt einen mir an chaosradio-ticker.berlin.ccc.de mit dem Subject Aufnahme Chaosradio-Ticker. Das ist die Information, die ihr detailliert auf der Webseite. Und dann tragt ihr euch in die Meldingsliste ein und bekommt immer nach den Sendungen automatisch die gesammelten Informationen. Und was wir meinen, was noch von Interesse ist, auch das, was ihr uns jetzt noch per Mail schickt und was vielleicht auch noch mit dort eingestossen werden sollte.
Ich mach mal ein Mikro an und hab auch noch ganz kurz was zu sagen. Die Seabase-Gestelliste ist rappelvoll. Da könnt ihr nicht hin. Ich spiel nach dem Fritz kurz empfehlen noch mal den Trailer zu dieser Aktion am Dienstagabend, die auch euch alle sicher sehr interessieren wird und die auch allen anderen sehr viel Spaß machen wird, kann ich euch versprechen. Mehr dazu dann am Dienstag. Und die Leute, die ihr angerufen habt auf der Gastliste sind, die sind genau das für andere. Da haben wir leider keinen Platz mehr. Karten kann man dafür nicht kaufen und man kann da auch nicht einfach hingehen, weil die Seabase einfach nur eine bestimmte Kapazität hat und wir da einige Sachen planen und dann ist einfach irgendwann voll. Aber ihr könnt dann halt am Radio zuhören und wenn ihr Internetzugang habt, auch da mitmachen. Und auch wir planen nicht nur Internetspiele und so, sondern auch See You See Me und so weiter. Ihr könnt uns hier sehen, wir können euch sehen und so weiter. Aber dazu am Dienstag mehr. So, was hatten wir noch? Ach so Banken. Wollen wir das nach einem Kurzinfo machen? Wird ein bisschen länger, oder?
Nicht unbedingt, also jetzt haben wir ja noch 6 Minuten. Die Frage war, wenn ich das noch richtig sehe, wie ist denn das, sind die TANs und die Pins und Internet? In Home Banking ist das sicher. Ein Dauerbrenner.
Jein. Also beim Home Banking gibt es prinzipiell immer drei Angriffspunkte. Das eine ist der Computer der Bank, das zweite ist der Übertragungsweg und das dritte ist der PC des Kunden. So. Es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Es gibt zum Beispiel die Idee, im Übertragungsweg fängt man einfach PIN und TAN ab, simuliert dem Kunden, er habe eine Verbindung mit der Bank aufgebaut, sagt ihm, ja ja, alles klar, Überweisung entgegengenommen. In Wirklichkeit hat man jetzt sozusagen PIN und TAN ergerndet und kann dann gegenüber dem Bankcomputer im Inneren eine Transaktion machen. Das wäre das Simpelste. Aber das geht nur, wenn man den Zugriff, den mehr oder weniger entschlüsselten oder unverschlüsselten Zugriff, mehr auf diesen Datenkanal hat. Ist also eher lästig, weil das mittlerweile alles verschlüsselt gemacht wird.
Oder wenn man auf ein Angebot eines Fälschers hereinfällt, wo man sozusagen auf einer Website auf einmal das Gefühl hat, man hätte es mit seiner Bank zu tun. Es ist auch möglich, dass Internetadressen für kurze Zeit gefälscht werden, so dass, das hatten wir vorhin mit diesem DNS, wenn man eine Anfrage macht, geht mir www.meinebank.de, dass sich jemand dort dazwischen hängt und eine andere IP-Adresse übermittelt. Und dann kommt man genauso, wie man es gewohnt ist, auf eine Seite, die vielleicht genauso aussieht und vielleicht auch sogar genauso funktioniert bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt, bis grüne Fehlermeldungen auftauchen, bloß in dem Moment hat man Tanz und so weiter schon eingegeben, und die Abhochung läuft vielleicht sogar schon längst. Also es gibt da sehr viele Gefahren und die Diskussion ist in Gange.
Vielleicht noch kurz zum letzten Punkt, zum Angriff auf den PC des Kunden. Also da gab es gestern gerade eine Möglichkeit im Fernsehen gezeigt. Die funktionierte also mit diesem ActiveX, was auf den Microsoft Explorer aufsetzt. Wo man glaubt, man guckt sich eine Website an. Dabei wird eine kleine Modifikation auf seiner Festplatte vorgenommen, nämlich seiner Homebanking Software wird einfach ein Transaktionssatz hinzugefügt. Das funktioniert also so, dass man da manchmal sein Programm startet, und dann macht man hier und da tricht man Überweisungen an, und irgendwann schickt man die dann alle gesammelt, gebündelt, mit Pins und Tans eben zur Bank. Und in dem Sinne würde man dann einfach eine Transaktion, also ein Überweisungsatz mehr, losschicken, ohne dass man das groß mitkriegt, weil wenn man fragt, dass Ding teilweise nur gebündelt nach einer TAN, also Transaktionsnummer führt, sind Überweisungslässe teilweise dann eben nach fünf statt nach vier Überweisungslässen. Und lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, es gibt da viele Angriffspunkte im Moment. Und vor allem gibt es eine ganz große Frage, nämlich wer haftet denn? Und es gibt im Moment nur eine Bank in Deutschland, die gesagt hat, wenn da ein Missbrauch geschieht, dann haften wir. Alle anderen Banken machen das schlicht so, dass wenn der Kunde ein Problem hat, wenn ihm auf einmal drei Millionen Mark vom Konto fallen, dann hat er eben einen Scheiß, dann hat er eben Pech.
Welche Bank ist das, die ihr Haftung übernimmt?
Das ist die Sparda Bank in Hamburg. Die macht das ein bisschen komplizierter. Die haben einen Me-Chip, also einen Chip zwischen Tastatur und Computer, damit die Eingabe der THNs schon verschlüsselt im PC landet. Weil die PC sowieso unsicher sind, ist auch nicht ganz falsch.
Und das ist auch der richtige Weg, das muss man dazu sagen.
Ja, kostet aber die Sparda einfach eine Mark mehr. Aus der Sicht des Kunden kann das eigentlich alles schnürrt sein, solange die Bank die Haftung übernimmt. Und das macht eben aus verständlichen Gründen nur die Sparda in Hamburg. Deswegen kann man im Moment von Home Banking schlicht nur abraten. Ist noch nicht so weit und vor allem nicht... Also man muss ja aussehen, da wär ne Menge Leute arbeitslos. Also Home Banking ist einfach die klassische Killer-Applikation im Sinne einer Arbeitslosigkeits-Applikation. Wo eben Filialen wegfallen, wo Leute irgendwie auf die Straße gesetzt werden, weil sie durch Computer gesetzt werden, was auch verständlich ist. Aber bitte schön doch nicht auf so ne Art und Weise.
Ja, außerdem ist es immer noch, solange sowas nicht völlig gebührenfrei ist, finde ich, ist es eine Frechheit, weil es spart immense Kosten für die Banken eben durch diese Arbeitsplatzverführung und dann lassen sie sich es auch noch bezahlen.
Ja und vor allem dann übernehmen sie noch nicht mal das Risiko der Technologie, das sie mit einführen. Also es ist einfach eine Verarschung. Und so sollte man es vorerst betrachten und abheften.
Tja, mehr Themen nach dem Fritz-Kors-Info.